there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock what's up you guys it's
awesome it's episode 152 yeah now this
is a really interesting topic that we're
doing day some it's kind of a little bit
different I guess yeah but we do true
crime we do true crime and I guess this
counts as true crime in their own robot
gangsters
yeah the old it the old classic mobsters
yeah of the United States yeah
specifically the Chicago Outfit of which
Al Capone was probably the best-known
remember the one that they made a lot of
the movies about Untouchables
yeah Goodfellas all that kind of stuff
so we're not big enough
well Goodfellas was that was that was no
yeah that modern times yeah that's true
70s I mean like I said the Chicago
Outfit is still around as far as I know
but we're kind of I might go a little
bit into that but I kind of feel like
probably we'll talk about the more
famous stuff that happened like in the
early 20th century and a lot of stuff
was going on around this time you know
some people yeah they kind of confuse
them and put them all together like you
know yeah
organized mobsters were basically in the
booze business they had nothing to do
with bank robbers and motorized bandits
like Bonnie and Clyde yeah a lot of
times people kind of think that there
was a big crossover not really 20s was a
wild time people who lost people lost
confidence in the American system and
you know you had guys basically waging
war against you know the the the banking
system and an entire police force it was
just another time you could do it back
then they didn't have it they did do it
I mean they got away with it for a long
time it's like a lot of these mobsters
and stuff I mean if they didn't get
[ __ ] rubbed out but rival gangs or
whatever a lot of them didn't really
serve any prison time or
not very much prison time because no
jury intimidation very you know bribery
various other reasons yeah a charisma to
yeah the higher you got up in these old
mob some more connections you had with
politicians and police chiefs you could
grease palms and the gangster of these
of this day you know they were providing
a service that people wanted which was
booze
they didn't people didn't want a
prohibition it wasn't popular and even
guys like camp own they were kind of
civilized in a certain way they were
tough but you could invite you can
invite Capone over to your house they
have dinner with him you could trust him
around your children and your wife you
know you could deal with him you
couldn't say it's a first a like the
Mexican mob or you know Colombian drug
cartels wouldn't it's not necessarily
like that but you could do that back
then and they did that ya know so they
had good press was what you'd call today
well and a lot of times and I think Al
Capone is like a you know kind of a
specific example of this too whereas he
made conscious effort to kind of burnish
his image by you know opening up soup
kitchens or like giving to charities and
you know various things of that nature
yeah and if you were law enforcement or
you were a few say you were police chief
you know that was on the take and or you
were a politician or a mayor you know a
senator even you could deal with Capone
he would keep up his end of the bargain
even they were I guess you could say
they were honest criminals yeah yeah in
a way like yeah I do feel like I mean Al
Capone's brief reign I mean he was kind
of only the boss really right like seven
years or something like it wasn't all
that great either
and yeah I mean his reign was was the
most violent because he did like provoke
gang wars whereas before there had been
like various truces oh yeah it didn't
count though for what I'm talking about
that was a soldier on soldier that was
gang on gang fighting over turf
sometimes civilians got in a crossfire
but if you were negotiating with him
yeah he would hold up his part of the
bargain
yeah now if you [ __ ] him over oh yeah
for sure oh yeah you were taking your
life as would pretty much any of you
most you're successful gangsters of this
era kept up their part of the bargain
yeah if you screwed them over they
killed you but that's just the way it
was yeah in some ways I guess it kind of
kept him in line everybody in line it
didn't always succeed because people
still [ __ ] you over anyway Brooke
well gangsters [ __ ] each other over
that's what no that's what I mean yeah
they did [ __ ] each other but they were
mostly negotiating with people of
authority and illegitimate people yeah
like cops and politicians and that's
they were being trying to be business
partners with people but in the culture
of the time I read a lot of books on it
you know you could invite these guys
over to your house yeah if you were a
cop you know and you could accept a
bribe from them and you could party and
have a good time they were popular guys
they and it was kind of prestigious to
have him around you know yeah and like I
said they were in a way they kind of had
like sort of a popular images still do
really I mean their their image even
though you know they were killers and
stuff like that they're kind of
romanticized I feel like it a lot of
movies and stuff like that right well
there's kind of a Roman Conover sack of
an ancient Roman mentality you know
where a man was judged you know his
virtues were judged accordingly a real
man was good to his friends and his
family and dependend defended his people
you know that's what he did but he also
punished ruthlessly his enemies he had
to do both yeah they will did you know
the the carrot and the stick you know
they were they would apply good and evil
on you that's how they got you know
that's that's that was for their virtue
yeah Romans were like that and some of
these gangsters yeah well and the ones
we're talking about our mostly Italian
yeah you know the Chicago at that time
the Chicago Outfit did have some other
unusually for the time it did have some
other ethnicities involved there were a
couple of Polish Jews in there there was
actually a Japanese American guy Tokyo
Joe you know so they had like a couple
of it wasn't you know all Italian
Italian Americans mostly Italian
Americans but like I said Irish
something well an Irish was there
like the rival gang though yet the North
Side gang yeah they were about a similar
mentality yeah I'd probably say that the
Italians were around longer because it
took them longer to integrate the Irish
could kind of change their name and the
long as they didn't have an accent they
could pretend to be an Anglo American
and they could marry and go straight
quick basic yeah cuz they still go on
English yeah took them in a couple extra
decades to kind of make the transition
yeah so let's do a couple of shout outs
and like I said I actually appreciate I
can't remember who it was cuz it was a
while back and I just wrote it on my
list and then it just kind of came up
this week but whoever recommended this
topic because I probably wouldn't have
thought to do it but once I started like
I'm like yeah that'd be actually a
really good show cuz it's like kind of
interesting and I was always been kind
of into this kind of [ __ ] so you know so
thanks to whoever recommended it however
long ago yeah so let's do a couple of
shout outs now for our $20 or not
patrons as I said with all of the
t-shirts have been sent out yeah we had
a problem with this you know some of you
that might get this I don't think it's
that many but a couple of you like them
that get them yeah they might have
postage due on them yeah $1 so what
ended up happening was that we sent all
of them out in one day and padded
envelopes yeah in like Pat like 8 by 10
padded emblem yeah and we sent them all
out and we thought everything was fine
like you know I just used the you know
the the self-serve postal machine the
robot for all the domestic ones and then
like I went inside because I had a few
that had to go over yeah International
won't be yeah that's they went totally
on Ireland they did that but so I did
all those and then the very next day
like half of them or maybe a little more
than half of them were returned and we
couldn't figure out why we're like why
did we get these back like it said that
it wasn't you know I mean so we took
them back to the post office and they
were like oh that's because you mailed
them as f1 you mailed them as envelopes
and you shouldn't you should have mailed
them as packages even though it was an
envelope but it's a padded envelope so
they sent half of them but then the
other half to send back to us yeah so we
had to remail miss
which you know cost us an extra by like
two or three bucks per unit hurt yeah
so the other half they said she had
safaris Idaho yeah they never came back
they said they probably sent him Okocha
postage due
that was like well [ __ ] so you may
either get a notification from the post
office that you got to go to the post
office hours get you shirt or they might
just say [ __ ] it maybe they sent half of
them directly to you and then they sent
half back to us to let us know not to do
that again that could happen that could
happen true because cuz like seriously I
had no idea
firstly why they all came back I was
like what the [ __ ] I because lots of
time once it came back to us we had to
pay postage again on yeah and that was
equal to what the stuff that they said
something they figured washed them back
to us it was exactly half yeah maybe
they were trying to go she ate with us
yeah why I don't know they'll probably
their prized show up to you yeah you
know but they have all been sent out now
yeah if you get a notification that
there's something at the post office for
you that's what it is it's that t-shirt
yeah so don't be weirded out it's yeah
they're gonna want a couple of scary or
nothing right that yeah it would only be
like maybe two or three dollars yeah all
right so um yeah so we got that out of
the way we're also going to do I also
designed a new logo shirt it looks
badass
it's much better than the other one yeah
the other one we had was cold this one's
even better me and Jenny on its bigger
yeah our faces are bigger it's different
pictures I use different pictures yeah
yeah so we'll probably send those out
next time and like I said we look like
vampires in it [ __ ] I did find some good
footage it's funny like fine photos that
are gonna work out I'm like yeah on
single-color screen print you know they
have to be like really striking then
like able to be poster eyes but yeah
these came out good but we're gonna I
burn this tag didn't this grainy the
transparency we still have to burn the
screen delay so next quarter you guys
get those yeah and we you know like also
mom yeah eventually we're going to set
up a store to sell them online too
because somebody was asking me about
that I said we do have a Zazzle store
yeah and it has like a whole bunch of
different shirts on it but the ones that
we screenprint were eventually going to
set up a store
do that we just haven't I think they'll
be a bit cheaper if not I can definitely
say that the longevity of these shirts
gonna be a lot better yeah a little bit
cuz that's a my billion spent mostly I
think all right so that's all that taken
care of
also I want to thank our pal Melanie who
sent us another PayPal dude yes thank
you very much you should be getting your
shirt very soon - we sent her a shirt as
well okay and we also had a new PayPal
donation from Lindsey and Todd so hi you
guys thanks very much for your first
very generous thank you how much
donation they're always very much
appreciated yeah also Tom got a really
cool birthday present
oh yeah already talked about that
oh no I thought I talked about that
already no okay yeah because I got a lot
of birthday presents you talk yeah
our friends Sophie the one that came one
came visiting this she said we were
pretty cool poster damn gigantic of the
thing and it's a painting of it it's bad
yeah it's not from the movie I mean it's
from the movie but it wasn't from that
Tara it's a modern yeah paint I'll take
what wouldn't so we'll slide in a photo
of it yeah yeah it's got crustle
Keith in there Keith David yeah all the
guys from the thing yeah I think cross
will had a splash like seen the flash
lighter frame though I remember it's all
purple yeah it's a newer poster oh
that's really neat
yeah that's our part Ark spent all the
guys in around a burned up body with the
[ __ ] shadow yeah when they burned up
yeah yeah she is a friend of the show
also a patron and you actually came and
visited us last couple months ago yeah
yeah she taught her how to make that
curry
she's trying to make curry yeah [ __ ]
up rice she doesn't know how to cook
cook rice she's figured a lot of people
have trouble with right-sides now I'm
yeah you take rice soaked rice if in
most here like jasmine rice and PES
minute and basmati rice yeah you wanted
to soak it okay so go for a few minutes
all right and then rinse it off in luck
a mesh wire mesh strainer get it get
everything off of it throw that in a pan
or pot actually for every cup of that
soaked rice it's a cup and a half of
water putting it put a cup and a half of
water in there cover it let it turn it
on full blast as soon as it starts
boiling over just take it off the fire
and set it aside 20 minutes later to be
done keep it covered yeah yeah it always
comes out perfect every time is that
exact same we make it we usually make 2
cups of rice at a time yeah 2 cups of
rice in the in like a big yeah pan like
that 3 cups of water after it's washed
and soaked - those 3 cups of water yeah
bring it to a boil covered just take it
off set it aside 20 minutes later it's
done and it always comes out yeah I used
to toast it and everything let's take
drop you could also take like basmati
take the rice grades wash them off throw
that into a pan with searing hot oil
that's in there and toast it yeah and
then throw the water in there and cover
it do the same thing it's nice oh yeah
and you've done it before - it's like
all different spices and they're so slow
like yeah probably doing a Food Show
though oh that's another thing I want to
mention - this is something we've been
discussing yeah um you know we're still
gonna do all our other shoes we're still
gonna do the matinee show if you've
noticed like the last couple weeks we've
only seen two movies just because it
didn't work out with the slots and there
was a holiday and stuff but um we're
still gonna do the matte nation and
everything like that because that's like
pretty easy for us to do but we've also
been thinking because we go off on
somebody like food religions yeah that's
some [ __ ] funny a story and this is
something that you know we're really
into cos Tom you know cooks a lot and
yeah you know we're all kind of
interested in like food history and like
retro food and stuff yeah I was
professional cook you know before army
and then off and on you know I mean when
I had to go back into the kitchen yeah
for a few months until another job came
along but you know it's not my from a
bad [ __ ] working in kitchens hell but
I do love to cook
yeah and I got a lot of stories about
food and food history when we can do
some [ __ ] funny shows about that yeah
there's some weird food out there we've
got all kind of like stories about yeah
like you know we've kind of gone into a
little
about like little Debbie's when we were
thinking about the other day cuz we were
talking about this [ __ ] weird-ass
like Lance crackers crackers like
they're like cheese cracker you heard
they like toast cheer whatever the [ __ ]
they're called there's a story behind
all so we were like talking about that
the other day I was talking balling
captain's wafers or so and he was like
you know we should do a whole other show
yeah about just like food history and
just like the companies that made it the
companies that make it and ya know how
that happened what years were talking
about who owns those companies now you
know that because I find that kind of
[ __ ] fascinating like I am fascinated by
food hich how it was more restaurant
history also transcendental I like aspic
yeah like what the [ __ ] were they
thinking just all kinds of aspect yeah
like why everything in you know the 50s
to the 70s had like [ __ ] olives and
pimentos in it yeah gotta cheese yeah
they put in there yeah why why was the
food so limited what you know I mean did
okay I've got some old cookbooks back
there that came from my grandmother I
know they're great
alright they were like friended like in
the late 30s and spaghetti is under
foreign food yeah yeah that cracks man
and they're in that sauce recipe they're
talking about is only like three
seasonings salt pepper sugar and oregano
that's it yeah oregano oregano
dandelo yeah and then to explain to you
what reggae no is in there yeah there's
a thing called oregano you can find it
in that in special themed places and
everybody's like it was just tomato
paste in water and there may have been
garlic in it that's some SpaghettiOs
[ __ ] right yeah yeah that's like that
was like yeah franco-american spaghetti
I would rather have Chef Boyardee
that probably tastes better yeah
what they were talking about Chef
Boyardee I don't get it
but yeah so we've actually been I'm not
sure like when this will happen but I'm
kind of excited about doing this because
like I said this is something I find
really interesting I subscribe to like a
bunch of blogs like mid-century menu and
all I kind of said I love that because
she if she like makes recipes like from
old cookbooks back then and so we're
thinking about doing another for I don't
know we're gonna call it yet like [ __ ]
up food or something yeah there's a
whole bunch of old candies that are
around that have weird stories behind
them soft drinks you know it's just
doesn't I mean it's just like an endless
font an endless supply of conversational
material in the food industry yeah yeah
so I feel like a restaurant in the
future we will probably be adding we
might not do it every week just because
you know it'll be like too much work but
we might do it one every two weeks or
one you know it's gonna be will be
talked about good food and then we're
also gonna be ragging off food too Oh
scary frames yeah old restaurants we
remembered as a kids like I imagined I
imagine most of you [ __ ] aren't even
young enough to have ever eaten in a
Sambo's hour my first ambos from yeah I
went to Tennessee when I was four years
old to visit relatives yeah there was a
Sambo's there and I was like its height
Sam used to love them used to love him
and out in California they were kind of
like Diddy's yeah it was similar but it
was like old Denny's it's not like the
titties you have now and they had all
these damn paint left really paintings
they were kind of like mosaics on the
walls made out of that damn what's that
[ __ ] crazy ass plastic these two have
in the 60s yeah all shiny what they come
not bakelite but no lucite yeah yeah
this lucite stuff and they were little
images of the story from [ __ ] tiger's
chasing a little black [ __ ] black [ __ ]
and in most of the most of the most
injured do things he has pretty [ __ ]
cringy but it wasn't doesn't see
Mukherjee at the time and [ __ ] [ __ ] he
had a turban on his head you know he
wasn't he wasn't African he was Indian
yeah from the India
like [ __ ] from Johnny yes I need a
little glass but you remember that me
just like [ __ ] fit and yeah but then I
remember got progressive they turned all
the Sambo's white I was old enough
remember that ok I don't say that yeah
it started off dark brown I remembered
him like this yeah about time I was
about 9 or 10 I noticed that they were
all white what happens all the Browns
yeah funny
well the only time I ever I had never
seen I don't I don't know if we had any
of them in Florida like I was pretty
little but I remember distinctly we went
on a road trip to Tennessee when I was
forward to visit my great-grandmother
and they they took us to a Sambo's there
and I had never heard of it before it
was good man everything I have had some
in Florida but everybody everything had
MSG in it so the flavors were just
through the roof I mean I remember being
really flavorful yeah you know [ __ ]
pigs in a blanket there's like little no
it weren't pigs in a blanket
they were like rolled-up sausage wieners
Nestle sausages you say I said weeners
ya little wiener you know like that like
sausage just like the way you said it
was just I don't know anything about
wieners oh I don't know anything about
wieners this one did you told me okay
they look like a little down yeah they
look like a Vienna sausage but they were
American sausages they'd roll them up
inside of a pancake and pour syrup all
over them I think there was eggs to nose
kid and I think they call it pigs in a
blanket I think that's what they called
it
I have to go back those old menus still
exist I'll look him up I'll remember
yeah like I said look online some of
that [ __ ] yeah hobo Jos remember that
one I've heard of that yeah yeah I used
to go to that Mattoon California every
every restaurant was filled with [ __ ]
statues of bums
yeah what was that all about and it was
a railroad theme about bums on railroad
like hobos and hobos [ __ ] crazy
Thurber man has imagined
just love those a kid even [ __ ] eat
these things called prairie dog
drumsticks yeah and guess what prairie
dog drumsticks were what they were
[ __ ] wings buffalo wings okay but it
was like the prototype of that yeah they
didn't they didn't have a cool name they
never cool name they didn't understand
they were crying they were fry but they
weren't they weren't thrown in in sauce
the sauce normally you know you you just
fry a piece of chicken and you make a
50/50 mix of melted butter and Tabasco
sauce and toss it in that and that's
what Buffalo Wildwood well they weren't
tossing it in anything it was just fried
and then they gave you a blue cheese
dressing or ranch either blue cheese or
ranch I think it might have been blessed
own tree stick and celery sticks I think
that's what was an infringement so
similar to the French fries yeah so
pretty much exactly the same yeah prey
drugs dog drama stages Colin and every
meal was named after some of mom would
eat his [ __ ] nuts man that was
[ __ ] nuts okay this is why that show
that's gonna be a teaser for this year
this is why this show I'm doing that now
yeah like I will tell you [ __ ]
stories as [ __ ] they have a [ __ ] that
went down inside these restaurants when
I was little like weird-ass right and
you were like telling about calvo's and
elbows in California yeah that was like
a tiki yeah [ __ ] it was a bizarre
place man and then there was uh [ __ ]
hanging from the ceilings and dried both
fish and [ __ ] peanut butter jelly
sandwiches mashed in between the loose
side of the glasses and glass window
some weird-ass [ __ ] [ __ ] drunks made
it it was awesome Ferris 300k we got to
give them yeah we're old school taco but
old school del Taco the Del Taco that
you you know the one that's around here
we had yeah yeah we had two of them
Miranda yeah that's good yeah the
original wasn't like that yeah the
original was from California and it was
like worse than Taco Bell but I remember
the original outlets and yeah is worse
and talked about I like del Taco
but yeah I mean the one we have around
here it's like really kind of -
jack-in-the-box out of our way
jack-in-the-box used to run into a
little rowdy on the round right yeah I
used to run around
you know when I was in California my mom
he's take me down to the pike run I ran
into Rodney Allen Rippy who was his
parents owned jack-in-the-box yeah he I
thought for the life of me I thought
riding Allen Rigby was one of the
Jackson 5's for a long time because I
grew up there's a little kid loving the
Jackson 5 and seeing Michael Jackson
when he was you know he's on a little
bit older than me he must have been five
or six when he was dancing yeah yeah
nice to [ __ ] see Michael Jackson
songs you know when he was with Jackson
five and I was a little kid and then I
saw Rodney Allen Rigby he was on all the
jack-in-the-box commercials and he was a
little black kid so I thought that I
thought that Rodney Allen Ricky was 180
Jack survives and when I saw him cuz I
ran into him at the pipe and his mom was
there his mom my mom were talking enough
talk jet I'm just jacked they're [ __ ]
rowdy out and Rigby and I thought you
know I was thinking about something
where's Michael Jackson yeah I'm like
six or seven where's Michael Jackson
yeah he was like what do ya'll hey you
know they looked alike back then when
they were kids they hid in the same hair
and everything you know and you they
play on television right on in the same
day so they had to know each other all
the people on TV oh yeah they also each
other yeah they're all inside there
hanging they're all hanging out yeah
yeah I see commercials for
jack-in-the-box you know right alongside
you know Jackson 5 you know making an
appearance something uh you know on some
show during TV so I thought you know
they all we're all hanging there I mean
yeah yeah I can see that they're all in
the Jackson 5 everybody is in the
Jackson there's like 20 of them they're
all in the Jackson 5 the Jackson 5
hundred yeah alright so yeah so maybe
we'll be doing that show what's the
point Google Rodney Allen Rigby there
was there was a whole episode just go on
YouTube
squad you to go jack-in-the-box Rodney
Allen Rigby and look at those
commercials and he's in those
commercials talking and if you're a
little kid you would think that he was
also in the Jackson 5
yeah yeah all right so you you want to
talk about gangsters okay all right so
specifically like I said you know it
would be like it would take forever I'd
like to talk about like the entire
American Mafia and all the other
gangsters and stuff like that so we
wanted to concentrate mostly on the
Chicago Outfit and Al Capone like during
Prohibition and all that yes
so we'll kind of go into that I'm going
to go a little bit into the history of
the Chicago Outfit where it came from
and all this other kind of stuff all
right all right so let's kind of go back
to the beginning um all right so the
Chicago Outfit that cities branch of the
American Mafia um now the way it's
organized today as I said it's still
around in a much less you know flashy
kind of state than it used to be back in
its heyday um but it's kind of heyday as
I said was sort of during the beer Wars
of Prohibition and during the reign of
Al Capone which was actually you know
pretty brief now along with the very
famous five families of New York City
five big crime families the Chicago
Outfit also has a seat on what they call
the Commission governing the Italian mob
in the United States now this kind of
goes back to the early 1900s so there's
a very large influx of Italian
immigrants into the Chicago area now
there are a lot of them were like street
gangs a lot of them are like little kids
and stuff now there were also not
necessarily organized but there were
things that were called black hand
schemes now I think later on in the
media they kind of made it seem like
these were you know organized crime
contingents but that's not necessarily
what black hand was black hand was more
like a method than an organization it
kind of originated in Italy like even
back in the 1700s I think they had this
kind of [ __ ] it's basically an extortion
racket what you would do is you would
you would write a letter to somebody
with money that you wanted and you would
threaten them
like you threatened to kidnap them or
kill them or burn their [ __ ] down or
whatever and then what they would do is
they would like draw like a little black
hand on it or like a little noose or
like a skull and crossbones or some [ __ ]
like that and you would send them a
letter and say hey I'm gonna murder you
unless you send me five thousand dollars
fifteen thousand dollars whatever it is
so eventually this kind of scheme which
was usually independent contractors it
wasn't usually dudes that were like
organized in any kind of logical you
know or any kind of big sense so you
know that there was a lot of that going
on and then that eventually came came to
be termed black hand because that was
like a lot of the iconography that would
show up on the letters so this kind of
[ __ ] was going on but then right around
like the 1920s there was this guy named
Giacomo Cola Simo otherwise known as Big
Jim and he was actually a brothel owner
in Chicago he had like a [ __ ] ton of
brothels that he was running and what he
had done was kind of like coalesced like
a lot of the criminal activities that
were going in the area including a lot
of these kind of independent Blackhand
the kind of operators and so he kind of
like got everybody together into a more
organized kind of setup like more like
an organization now into this you know
organization he introduces his nephew
whose name is Giovanni Papa Johnny
Torrio one thing I love about gangsters
and I think this is probably one of the
reasons that a lot of people still like
them is their adorable nicknames
some of them have stupid ones been some
of them have really really good one it's
mostly just the way I remember it
somebody yeah that's a distinguishing
feature yeah I mean Al Capone very
famously known as Scarface yeah cuz he
had a scarf yes
which I'll explain how I got that soon
but yeah so Papa Johnny Torrio comes
onto the scene who was the nephew of Big
Jim Colosimo
now 1919 Torrio was the guy that brought
Al Capone into the fold and now Capone I
believe was only a
19 at the time so let's talk a little
bit about Al Capone since we're on that
topic I feel like you want to say
something you know about Al Capone yeah
distinguishing feature of Al Capone that
they say at this age is that he was big
he was yeah he's very round individual
and he could he can intimidate people
and it was pretty good with his fists no
that's really how he came up from
nothing
and he was ruthless yeah and he wasn't
dumb he was he wasn't he was a smart guy
yeah that's really you know that's you
know when you're talking about a very
low-income area that's what it takes to
me to me yeah so you know he had a good
pedigree for his time up to do this yeah
yeah this doesn't come out of the middle
class of the underclass they don't have
a need for this well no business go to
school be big they have prosper they
have prospects if you don't have any
prospects then you got a you know your
genetic you've got to find other ways
yeah there's other ways you know I mean
and there's a stir there's a genetic
component there really is that's
interesting that you should say that
because now Al Capone was actually a
first-generation American his parents
were immigrants from Salerno and his
parents were actually rather respectable
as deaf as a barber his mom was a
seamstress all of their children had
very normal upbringing however I think
pretty much all of them except for the
girls and the one that died in infancy
turned out criminals yes so I think that
was kind of just uh probably a function
just of the environment like you said
because it you know it wasn't really
there was so much gang [ __ ] going on
there was so much criminal activity
going on it was easy way to make money
it was faster - yeah exactly a lot of
these people from these neighborhoods
you know died okay yeah they died of
poverty really if you look into it they
were working hard jobs they got killed
on a job that got sick really couldn't
afford give themselves the proper
treatment
you know they lived hard lies maybe
because they couldn't afford you know
the proper heating during the winter
eating bad food it's just your your
chances of survival long-term in the
lower edge of socio-economic levels back
in that era your prospects weren't very
good so in a way guys like Capone dudes
that we're doing that we're in a way
kind of like fighting for their lives
they're trying to fast-track yeah it was
an understandable rotten I mean because
for them from their point of view is
probably like a logical yeah you either
Sorento me there sit here and [ __ ]
just fade away in obscurity
yeah or you can fight and try to make
something out of yourself they really
didn't have it within their means to do
it like the appropriate way or the you
know what I mean that the middle-class
way yeah so they did it this way now
this goes back into their psychology and
you're gonna see this over and over
again their theme the main thing they
want is [ __ ] societal approval yeah
they want status they want to be oh yeah
I just want a particular yeah they want
to be worth they want to be respectable
they want to be known they want to be
accepted they want to wear expensive
stuff do really they're really kind of
peacock guys in a way they're oh yeah
that definitely describes up capoeman
going back to that the Italians were
special when it came to this because
like I said it was just kind of in them
genetically going back and culturally
going back to the ancient Roman times
where I said a man was judged by how how
well he defended his family and his
friends and how ruthless he was to his
enemies if they weren't fighting enemies
and destroying enemies then they weren't
doing their job that was kind of the
they were a full-spectrum kind of guy
yeah you know well it's kind of an honor
bound your altar yeah so you can and how
it translated when they didn't mix too
well with angle America you know the
Anglo Germanic side of our society is
kind of a legal based system
you know I'm talking about where there
were courts and their laws you know they
weren't into this vendetta stuff yeah
that's why ancient Rome was though my
dad you know she looked at what ancient
Roman law was it was mob rules in a way
in bribery you know it so it was a
cultural conflict I guess you could say
in a certain way that's a good way of
putting it you know a very diplomatic
way yeah and there are strengths and
weaknesses to both sides yeah they're
what these guys are doing is not illegal
but in a way when you look at
situationally you know you kind of have
I kind of have this problem with kind of
admiring their I think a lot of people
do I think there's like even though I
mean from one point of view obviously
these were not nice guys they would if
you [ __ ] them over they perceived that
you [ __ ] them over then they would
just shoot you in the face and not even
like feel bad about it they bombed
places and killed innocent people
without feeling bad about it again just
to get back at rivals or whatever or to
get what they wanted so these were not
good guys they considered themselves
with cross between like cops judges and
soldiers and businessmen they were all
kind of they were judge jury and
executioner they were everything just
all wrapped up into watch yeah you know
they're basically just like taking
everything yeah yes
like I said in another era I can kind of
understand how that would how that's
kind of cool yeah but you have to have a
civilization basically it's kind of run
by rules in law and order that that kind
of works out I think better for
everybody in the long run it does yeah
yeah I mean this kind of [ __ ] works out
probably works out better in the short
run and and in a local area small area
in a local area it's not big thinking
and it really it's really not no yeah
it is very kind of way but it was
another era this is the 20s a lot of
what they were doing back then you just
couldn't do it today computers would get
you cameras oh yeah and like I said even
though the Chicago Outfit as far as I
know does still exist today
I mean they've had like a lot of you
know
I mean the you know law enforcement has
kind of gotten infiltrated the gangs and
everything and they don't have like this
way that they used to have I mean back
in the old days they used to [ __ ] run
the police force what like half the
police boys on Capone's payroll at least
that's what he claimed another problem
is that this type of gangster needed
prohibition to flourish they were saying
liquor yeah and look everybody wanted
liquor I mean they had other [ __ ] yeah
but they were kind of like Robin Hood's
yeah it was liquor and women yeah guys
are the the people of that era wanted to
drink and they were told not to by the
law that wasn't popular and some of
these married women women wanted to run
with these young prostitutes and they
wanted that and the mob was giving it to
him so they kind of had a Robin Hood
kind of yeah all right to them like they
were given the comment people never give
me out kind of what they wanted yeah now
when they go to war with each other and
cassadee's that happened and it was bad
but they would kind of spin that in the
media to kind of bolster their image of
power yeah you know oh yeah I'm a nice
guy and I'll kill you
don't you want to be my friend you don't
want to be my enemy look at where my
enemies are they're dead look what my
friends are concrete's they're making
money and happy call me come play with
us come join the team no that's the way
they were booze and hookers booze and
hookers and you do canes you have me and
I help you and you come up against that
how I will I will bury you
you know that's it's my language I
understand Barney's run really is just
it is like I said it is very similar and
you can see why I'm still romanticized
yeah to this day yeah in a way that like
modern gang culture is not romanticized
as far as we know as far as we know
maybe in other countries yeah at the top
levels you know some of this bad stuff
that happens is that the very low level
of those organizations or its
unorganized crime you know yeah so but
it's not worth it it's not worth messing
with these dudes well no I think I think
we can look at what's happening nowadays
you know a lot of the real criminal
stuff is happening way up high with a
rich guys and that was another thing is
that these guys really if you look step
back and looked at him they weren't that
rich they had power they had stuff but
they were nowhere is enriches say you
know some of these guys in Silicon
Valley yeah you know I'm a nurses so
well Capone I mean under Capone's
leadership I mean it was making like a
female a year like even back in the day
a lot back there which was a lot of
money back then but that's about a
midsize corporation size yeah yeah and
think of the risks yeah so yeah the
rewards were great we're just kind of
shot right yes I mean a lot of it's
funny if you look at the Wikipedia page
for the Chicago Outfit it has like a
little chart at the bottom of like all
the capos and like all the bosses and
stuff and how many yeah it was most
defense yeah that was a problem I was
the problem between these Italian
Italian mafia sand and the same with the
Irish towers were working with them they
got into too many [ __ ] fights with each
other over stuff well like I said I've
it's always been my opinion that dudes
are dudes or fishes yeah they are just
always having blood if they don't have a
beef with another dude they will invent
a beat another dude just so they can
have something to fight about yeah and
that was definitely the case here but
yeah so um yeah so let me talk about
because I talked a little bit about you
know the very ancient history so Al
Capone is kind of brought to Chicago and
when he was 19 years old now prior to
that Al Capone was actually not native
of Chicago was actually born in Brooklyn
New York as I said he was a first
generation American his parents were
I've read Salerno Naples is that even in
the same area I don't even know when I
read like two different everything in
Italy is in the same area by American
standards now
Al Capone he was actually the fourth of
nine children he went to school until he
was 14 when he was expelled after
punching a female teacher in the face
so after that he just said [ __ ] school
like I said he seemed like a very
intelligent guy but you know Authority
was kind of a problem know what he was
intelligent you couldn't get to his
position in these kind of organization
oh yeah and I think everyone has said
that that he wasn't actually a very
savvy businessman um in a very brief
list businessman like if you were just
in his way he would just like it's like
hey can you help this guy off Thanks
yeah so he gets out of school but he
like actually started he tried to kind
of have a respectable life he had like
some normal jobs like he worked in a
candy store
he worked in a bowling alley like as a
pin boy he worked in a munitions plant
um you know and he worked in a
bookbinder he stuff like that but while
he was having regular jobs he was also
hanging out with these quote-unquote kid
gangs like the 40 thieves juniors the
Brooklyn rippers South Brooklyn rippers
just these little kids you know that
would go around whatever they were doing
like kid gang stuff they're like shake
his purses off yeah like you know
stealing and breaking and entering why
not
vandalism petty crime all that kind of
stuff and like I said this is in New
York now at this stage you know when he
was a teenager he kind of gets
acquainted with Johnny Torrio who I
mentioned before who was in the James
Street Boys Gang and this was the guy
that would kind of become his gangster
mentor I guess you could say um so when
Al Capone was 16 he gets in with the
five points gang and he also makes the
acquaintance of this other gangster
named Frankie Yale who would kind of be
important later on now Frankie Yale was
a bartender at this saloon slash brothel
called the Harvard Inn now when Al
Capone was young I believe he was only
about 21 years old he was at the Harvard
Inn and he made um a crude comment to
this girl that was there I believe it
was something about her ass okay and her
brother came and slashed his face
mmm-hmm which is where the scar came
from hence his nickname Scarface now
this was even though the nickname
nowadays sounds super badass and there
was like even that whole Al Pacino movie
with the mountains of cocaine and all
that kind of stuff but Al Capone hated
that nickname a lot of these guys hated
their name George Nelson hated being
called big baby
well I can see yeah right it's a you
know what I mean it's like you want to
be like tough and everything and
everybody's calling calling you like
fluffy snuffles or something like that
it's like that's got the suck ray you
want a badass sounding name in a way
they were kind of complimenting Nelson
though that he looked y'all well that's
a yeah she kind of had a babyface and he
didn't have you know I don't he didn't
have facial hair and stuff and yeah you
know so but you know this is kind of
this actually kind of cracked me up now
suppose a bank robber in case you guys
don't know yeah there's an organized
bank robbery he hated cops
he actually waged war against them cops
and you can do a whole show on that yeah
and you could you could do it back then
because cop cars didn't have radios in
him that was the main thing
cop car without radios useless it's just
damn useless oh yeah because you could
kill that cop and who would ever know
yeah and they couldn't support one
another to call one another during a
chase to call for backup or whatever oh
man cats get rich she was trying to back
over the nose is that the way the United
States worked back then you can commit a
crime in one state and if you hopped
across all the cares moving it down you
crazy she's like what she's like I need
room she's trying to lay down the way
the way the interstate crime laws worked
back then you can commit a crime in one
state across the border and the other
state couldn't do anything to you
yeah so what should I bring about so
many murders like that like you like
raped and murdered like 50 women in one
state and then it's like hey I'm just
gonna like move over the state line dude
and then then we were out of
jurisdiction and nobody ever caught them
and then they had these they didn't have
interdiction and they didn't have
extradition cop
between the states though it was it was
insane so there that gave rise to what
was called motorized bandits and that
was like Bonnie and Clyde and some of
the other guys you know that did this
they drove around in cars robbing banks
and robbing people and killing cops and
doing weird [ __ ] like wiping out a
police station and then going to rob the
bank and they did it from car and then
you know there's some yeah yeah it's
like first let's blow up them and maybe
we're badasses they trendy then we'll
get around the pack yeah won't be around
to do it yeah and they would do things
like train with weapons they'd buy they
buy be ARS and cut them down and have
model highly modified really good
weaponry that was decades ahead of what
other people had they're trying to make
assault rifles yeah like that you know
they would just go okay we're gonna Rob
this Bank over here in this town but
let's go wipe out the police department
first and then we'll go there and we'll
just walk and get like three people
would do it they just took kill five
people in them police station and then
just go across the street and rob the
bank and get all the money and then they
just drive to it you know and stop yeah
and then just drive 20 30 miles across
the state lines and he couldn't touch
him yeah I do kind of wonder like no no
radios so they couldn't call ahead yeah
that's true
with her radios but there weren't your
radios in the cars yeah that was some
high-tech [ __ ] Magnum yeah yeah yeah so
like I was saying even though you would
think nowadays that Scarface is a pretty
badass nickname to have he really did
not like that name and this kind of
cracks me up okay so even though he got
the scar like I said from some dude
being like hey don't talk about my
sister's ass like that and slashing him
in the face he told everybody that he
got it in the war yeah because he was
never so super insecure about it and he
would also like whenever they
photographed him he would always like
try to show like the side of his face
without it yeah now ironically one
nickname that he did get that he did
like was his friends would call him
snorky he liked that man that is not
weird but it's like that actually means
I'll use a snappy dresser because he was
like super into like like he said like
kind of a peacock type of thing yeah and
he always had like kind of
expensive suits and you know fancy
underwear made out of Italian silk and
all this other kind of yeah and so
snorky and evidently based on what just
is just from memory Al Capone was very
good to women women liked him well his
wife seemed to like you be into him
yeah I mean she she he evidently was
remained happily now he cheated on her
and he got syphilis from Peterson stuff
yeah but well he had been doing that for
a long time
yeah he well he kind of grew up around
those kind of women yeah but yeah
evidently women that had dated him said
that he was just a good guy yeah and he
didn't like throw gangster weight around
on them he was she was trying to escape
that world yeah and he was with women
well I actually saw I was watching a
documentary about him today and the
documentary was quite old so there were
some people that you know there were
some older people on there that actually
had known him or like knew like hung out
in bars where he hung out and they said
he was a super popular he was a big
tipper
um and he was like super nice to all the
you know women that worked in these
brothels and like you know guys that
worked in the bars and stuff so they
always liked when he came in because he
yes he like gave everybody money and he
was like super nice to them yeah it's a
misconception that you would see on in
some of these movies that gangsters
walked around intimidating everybody no
you get yourself killed that way they
actually walked around complimenting
people in grease and palms and really
was popularity contests all these
successful gangsters from this era were
all peacock popularity type guys with
the general public
no with other gangsters difference
rivalry there you know sometimes I
didn't get along sometimes they had to
kill each other off that you know but
with the with the general public they
were constantly in PR mode which is
smart because if you if everybody thinks
you're a nice guy I mean if you just
walk around being a [ __ ] dick all
that everyone will turn on you then
everyone's gonna turn on you cuz they're
like yeah [ __ ] that dick you don't want
that in the
newspaper you want the newspaper how
everybody loves you yeah can't be true
what they're saying about you yeah and
that's usually what you read and then
papers about Al Capone yeah is that yeah
they're right after him because he
celled the boobs but of course everybody
knows how everybody else feels about the
booze he's such a great guy yeah he's a
common man well like I said what they
had on this ship on this documentary
that I watched they had this one woman
who I think she she was a dancer at like
one of the clubs that he used to
frequent and she said the same thing she
basically I don't know she said this
outright but she kind of implied that
she didn't think that he had done any of
this stuff yeah I mean she didn't say
that he wasn't a mobster but she said
that oh well he just always got other
people to do his stuff which he did a
lot of times but I think he did do some
[ __ ] was also um yeah oh yeah he'd kill
you yeah he was beating people up you
know before he was a big name
yeah and that's like I said this you
know all of this stuff that happened I
mean he did a couple of murders they
think like before he was even like 21 or
40 yeah um
when he was still kind of knocking we
were even in that era in that place in
time at his class level knocking people
off knocking off competitors is
something you had to do in your rise to
power you know I mean you wouldn't be
able to get anywhere if you didn't knock
out certain competition yeah usually
it's another gangster that's claimed a
certain turf that you want yeah and
that's essentially what he did right and
it could be that you know this guy and
he's a real [ __ ] and people don't
like him so you might think it you might
think you know if I kill this guy the
neighborhood's gonna [ __ ] think it's
great I'll take his place
yeah and I'll be good to over yet
another Rizzo not to be a dick even yeah
gangster exactly don't be a dick so
there's always another angle just to a
lot of this kind of stuff
in organized crime yeah and like you
said I think one of the reasons that Al
Capone is still so famous today is me
over that Barry he made a lot of him he
made a lot of good moves in his line of
work even though he did pretty much the
same [ __ ] that all the other gangsters
were
right but pride too did it to the right
ones yeah I kind of feel like that yes
politics politics you know there's
involved so like I said you know he's
still pretty young at this point like I
said he's only about 21 years old there
were rumors that he actually killed a
guy who had won a craps game in the
neighborhood he just basically shot him
and took all his money that he had just
won um there was more to it than that
yeah I'm just saying that these are all
as a rumor yes
some sources like say this kind of stuff
too um although he didn't get he didn't
get done for it because either nobody
witnessed the murder or everybody said
nope we didn't see anything you know so
it's one of those kind of situations
sorry kiddies kinda catching stuff with
her paw on her but you know she does
also he supposedly beat up a member of
the white head white hand gang who was a
rival of the gang that he was in at the
time now after he did that he left the
guy for dead but the guy survived so
because the guy had promised retribution
that was why um he ended up going to
Chicago like cuz at this stage I mean he
got married really young I think he was
only 19 years old and him and his wife
actually had a baby before they got
married it was one of those kind of
things where they had the baby first and
then they got married so he and he got
married me who's 19 so he had a wife and
kid at this point so because this other
rival gang member said well hey I'm
gonna kill you and possibly your wife
and child also so he just got sent to
Chicago to work for Johnny Torrio right
so this was about like I said this is
about 19 19 now this was about the time
now the the gangs like I said that had
been run by um Big Jim Colosimo at this
point they weren't that prohibition
hadn't come in quite yet so they were
doing like yet mostly brothels
prostitution gambling
you know racketeering that type of stuff
vegan pizza
we're gonna talk about probably okay
extra pizza this is Chicago Tom big
pizza Ross yeah I go she cut gangsters
are always fighting over who had the
best pizza well Chicago versus with you
Chicago pizza or New York Pizza I like
both kinds that's both good Chicago
pizza is what they call pizza pie it's
deep-dish sometimes it has another crust
over the top it's kind of like a cat
it's a meat it's a whole it's a whole
meal into itself yes deep dish this deep
dish yeah that's good
now Capone actually they asked if he was
interviewed on so I think at least one
occasion about pizza and they really did
asking about pizzas oh yeah this is a
big deal you guys like cookin if you're
not American there's like a huge list
it's a thing no like I said it's
generally New York style versus Chicago
yeah [ __ ] Capone there's a California
style homeless that's another thing
Capone was firmly behind Chicago
deep-dish pizza it is good firmly but I
like both kinds but it depends on what
man and the newspapers would tell you
exactly which pithan place he went got
that at I believe that I don't member
which one it was but yeah he wasn't
giving him a shout-out yeah and in that
era in that era Pizza was a foreign food
Americans Anglo Americans didn't eat
pizza well yeah this is the 1920 our
songs a lot [ __ ] you don't I mean yeah
do you need that [ __ ] you know but I'm
gonna go ahead and say that gangsters
made pizza famous I think gangsters made
you know I think that brought pizza to
the American mainstream now there are
other countries that have pizza Brazil
has pizza and they have their own
history with pizza there their pizza is
very different and I think probably you
know
Europe has pizza of course in its
history is very different American pizza
is American pizza it's not related to
the other pizzas although it comes from
immigrants comes from Italian immigrants
yeah alright but it has changed a lot
and been mutated Al Capone would have
told you if you were to ask
today if you were to ask al capone about
pizza he would say Chicago deep-dish
pizza is rich people pizza that at out
Italy was poor people's pizza they would
say yeah because American Thomas was a
land of plenty in comparison to Italy of
that day and over there it was basically
just a thin piece of bread with a little
bit of olive oil and some seasoning
maybe a piece of meat on there wasn't
much on it okay American deep-dish pizza
is an exaggeration of pizza yeah it's
like it's ridiculous it's got everything
on it it's what an Italian back in Italy
would have dreamed of having so
deep-dish pizza is the Italian dream
come true it's got all this [ __ ]
cheese on it and all this meat and all
these vegetables and that's that's a
real piece it's rich it's like a pizza
casserole or like it's a quiche yeah
yeah in a way it's thick
we've made them before like you take a
minute cast-iron skillet I make my own
dough yeah you may have to do put it in
there in the bottom but in a [ __ ]
cast on it's just I can do New York
style I can do - you know I love Italian
food murder want some pizza it's hard
well no it's very easy to mess up pizza
well it's very easy you can [ __ ] that
crust up you know me I'm I I obsess
about it's true it's that crust has got
to stay in there for about a day 24
hours at least the better on the second
day before you roll it out and cook it
and you got to do it on a stone yeah
high as possible 550 degrees possible
yeah shall be hot with good with real
mozzarella cheese buffalo yeah real real
not I'll use that parcel skim milk when
I have you because it's cheap and you
know I always have it there really it's
gotta be real mozzarella makes a huge
difference
Annie makes its own sauce I grow my own
girl grow my own basil basil out there
in the back growing just we see basil
leaves on
[ __ ] man I'm having every guy I'm gonna
have every Italian gangster over here
and you're gonna have to make it
otherwise you're gonna be wearing cement
shoes debicki now they're gonna come
back to its ha me boy Tommy make some
more pizza make someone a pizza
like I said Tommy big pizza Tommy big
pizza Ross rusty you got a hero science
is he's Italian but he's Irish but he
doesn't know that tag American me eatin
cookie cooked just like a [ __ ] dango
that's what the gangsters will be say
just like a Guinea all right so as I
said um you know so the kind of nascent
Chicago Outfit at the time that Al
Capone arrived in Chicago was still
doing [ __ ] like you know running
brothels and racketeering and whatever
now when Prohibition came along which if
you are not from the United States means
that they actually outlawed alcohol of
all things which is like their own it's
very funny for funny think about my kind
of [ __ ] did they think that was kind of
tell you why I'm tell you I learned it
didn't work so boy alert it was a small
minority of religious religiously
fervent women guilt-tripped people into
[ __ ] bass in that [ __ ] yeah it was
they're like going out drinking and
they're not responsible citizens and
that's what happens when so-called
morality gets in the way of [ __ ] man
don't stop me from drinking yeah morale
getting in the way of practicality I
mean there's everybody wears a drink
there's a lot of vices that I've given
up over the years but uh I like drinking
a prohibition drinking okay remember
when I said no when I said early on that
it's better to have a civilizations
based on rules and laws versus one
that's based upon what kind of you know
the mob way was really supposed to be
like an honor based society not so much
a legal basis ayat II well you but you
gotta look and you gotta look at it this
way
the mob way would never exist on its own
it has to have a legal system to
piggyback on - yeah because what it does
is it finds a way to make profit off of
breaking the law well yeah that's
exactly what it does
so had alcohol never been illegal the
mob never would have existed yeah or not
to the extent that they know I mean they
just have gained power that they gained
later already been hookers and maybe
like extortion rackets that's what they
were doing before yeah and maybe like
kidnapping people for ransom
that's probably whatever they able to do
but that's never mainstream alcohol that
was mainstream that's what I mean this
my hand did it right over to that they
did that was like the stupidest thing
ever and then that was like the rise of
the whole I mean the whole reason that
we're talking about the Chicago Outfit
that we're talking about the Mafia
nowadays is because of prohibition yep
that was pretty much like I said they
were around it was still that [ __ ] going
on but they passed that [ __ ] and [ __ ]
the mob was like cha-ching well Capone
was for sure yeah there's I saw an
opportunity we can become the heroes yep
everybody wants booze and we'll be the
party boys we had [ __ ] skip that
exactly they will love us and yeah
that's exactly what happened
don't take something that everybody
wants that's common and make that [ __ ]
illegal now the response will be
organized and we'll go we'll save you
company I mean how I don't know what the
percentage is what is the percent of
adult Americans not even like people
around the world I'm sure it's like much
higher in other countries adult
Americans that drink alcohol they drink
alcohol 95 % easy it's gotta be at least
two different degrees yeah I mean yeah
I'm not saying like I would say they're
even all the time but they're probably
only 15% teetotalers yeah it's very
rarely meet people say he's drink at all
you're gonna say 85% I mean unless
they're like Mormons or something or
they have some other like other
religious you know kind of thing where
they don't do I don't think I've ever I
haven't met that many our level our
level is probably about thirty percent
yeah I think we're in the top thirty
percent because we're like not
alcoholics yeah we're like the next
level
yeah yeah a real alkie a real alkie
that's right like i don't drink in the
daytime or nothing like that we rarely
ever see any real out piece that's
probably only yeah that's maybe we know
people that drink a lot but it's usually
just like once a week like they work all
week a normal job like they're a doctor
or whatever and then like Saturday night
they just go and get shit-faced hardcore
alkies that's probably about three or
four percent how much of it it's
probably not very high on yeah yeah I
don't think I've ever I mean you know I
know there's probably a lot of
alcoholics out there but I don't think
I've ever been anybody this is a
hardcore alcoholic but I you know I
don't meet that many people that don't
at least drink socially oh yeah most
people do so as I said prohibition from
you know from the jump was like the
stupidest idea ever done and like you
said it handed power essentially right
to it organized crime hower that's
exactly what they did
popularity it handed yep it handed the
world right over to those guys and that
was one of the reasons why they damn
were fighting over it so hard
mm-hmm they wanted to monopolize on it
they just started killing each other
over [ __ ] right that might have been
at night it was probably not all
Capone's doing no being particularly
ruthless it was just the situation
situated just scrambling although they
control this vast market that had just
been thrown on them and these were
small-time guys okay at this point
becoming a national industry and the
Kennedys came out of that may ended up
becoming [ __ ] presidents and [ __ ] okay
so it wasn't just the Italians it was
the Irish to the Kennedy family was
bootleggers they admit it so that's not
a conspiracy theory and you know that's
we've had presidents come out of that
family so it's weird how the Italians
didn't come up but I guess had to do it
the Italians being Catholic and the
timing and and everything now you could
have an Italian president Italian a
president yeah don't they know just that
they're just not really appearing cuz
the Italians have been here so long
doesn't mean there's American as apple
pie now exactly that there's like a hole
right so nobody thinks of them as quote
unquote for me I mean nobody that I know
and was there
but yeah so around 1919 1920 when
prohibition starts first started to come
around as I said the burgeoning Chicago
Outfit was still under the control of
Big Jim Colosimo now for whatever reason
I'm not entirely sure why but Big Jim
did not want to get into the liquor
business I don't know if it was for
religious reasons or if it was a good
idea I don't know why but so he didn't
want to get into it now Capone was like
ok well I think this is like a good
business opportunity and apparently
Johnny Torrio also agreed no there right
so they decided they were gonna rub his
ass out now they're not entirely sure
who assassinated Big Jim Colosimo some
people said it was Al Capone some people
said it was Frankie Yale who had owned
the brothel where Capone started out
what was the his vote on something no
they basically just wanted him out of
the way so they could get into booze
production he was distribution he was
impeding them
he was impeding so yeah he got the mob
we would say that we got to do that he
got assassinated yeah so that's what
they did he made the wrong decision
though he's a dumbass you should have
seen that's what I mean and like I said
I'm not entirely sure and maybe some
other source says like I've read like a
couple different sources this but no
source I said like gave a reason for why
he didn't want to get involved to you
know what they called run running or
bootlegging or whatever he didn't want
to get involved in that he was too dumb
to be in the mob I guess like I said I
don't know if he had religious resolve
they had to knock that link out of the
chain of command because he was too dumb
that that was an opportunity right there
they had millions of dollars off booze
well yeah and launched them to fight him
into [ __ ] everlasting Fame these guys
will always be famous yeah exactly yeah
yeah so they bumped him off and then
Johnny Torrio took over what was then I
don't know if it was known then as the
Chicago Outfit but that's what we know
now is the Chicago Outfit so actually
how long are we ok let's actually take a
break now so I can check on my notes and
kind of get these more rough get things
more organized organized and also see
what little baby cookie is doing back
there
with her I'm gonna make another drink
little but say you know um I still have
about a third left so probably fine but
and we're already at like an hour II I
want to be loaded by the time the show's
over the [ __ ] Olli I know he's gonna
be like yelling and definitely waving
his arms what the hell it's an hour in
our in eight minutes
okay good all right so we're gonna take
a break right now for drink refreshing
and note-taking and various other things
that we will be back in just
[Music]
[Music]
I can't wear a poop dude where you see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're back talking about Al
Capone and the Chicago Outfit [ __ ]
mobsters [ __ ] I'm in a bar or
something
talking about Tommy big was honor day
and I don't know what my gang name would
be like my monster name um I don't want
to say well I was gonna say have
deadbeat it would be a bad thing I was
gonna say about motors because that's
like my one decision yeah yeah yeah I
had a friend be like tits Ashford an
ex-friend yeah who used to call me tits
McGee yeah so that's what even though
I'm not well I'm partially the boobs the
boobs got something else other than
boobs it's like it listen the girls you
know I don't know the mammaries no I'm
trying to think of like a good too
high-minded they were just they were
just say I want a good be I don't want
my gangster name to be Jenny the tits
ass yeah yeah that's fries that's what
they would do I know
just break it down to the most memorable
aspect of you so they don't have to
actually memorize your name during the
meetings that's what those hey the tits
yeah yeah we rub out that one yeah
that's what these guys are doing hey the
Scarface guy what does that yeah yeah
it's exactly the guy with the arms and
here did Jimmy
big Jimmy not the little Jimmy and not
medium Ginny the big Jimmy's do the same
[ __ ] in the army then we had black dudes
they were all named were Brown and their
girlfriends would call on the public
phone we had we had like a payphone in
the middle of common air this is before
cell phones and be some sister on there
going yeah yeah we're brown I said which
brown dark brown light brown
and then Braun to be more like a browse
tell my dog brah hey come on run what's
up so she's on the phone which is yeah
yeah that's exactly what now light brown
and dark brown and medium brown
like I said which one is hot brown oh
I'm going back to if you ask them they
would all be hot bright they were hot
brown that's a hot dog
dudes Hattie goes man I have to say like
you know as shitty as the whole like
shooting everyone is I do really love ya
thanks Johnny I'm into that
this old this old gangster culture is
exactly a lot like military infantry
type [ __ ] we all had nicknames for each
other based on how you looked or things
about you or the series I know just Ross
that's easy to remember
okay but some of these guys had names
that were hard to remember yeah
sometimes a name would just kind of come
out of the blue you know sometimes it's
usually based around the guys last name
yeah use in the army but ya know a lot
of these names that's what you'd be
called in the army
yeah I guess if you had a distinguishing
one yeah some kind of sting wishing for
your future yeah specially if you're
Nate especially if your last name is
real common yeah you know time up or too
long yeah I'm like no it's like to say
that I'm say that [ __ ] right we're just
gonna call you
it's yeah yeah well he couldn't get away
man sits could you get away with that
today I mean you probably couldn't get
away that back in the back and those
where's tips huh hey that's what they
were talking
gimme the tits number toots
it's West hits well yeah all right so
we're going back to like I said the
beginning of prohibition and because Big
Jim
get into that business opportunity for
whatever reason he got rubbed out I
don't know if he was killed by Al Capone
specifically or if it was Frankie Yale
that did it most sources say that it was
one of those two guys but they bumped
him out and then like you know bumped
him up and then Torrio took over Johnny
Torrio took over now about this stage
like I said Capone was kind of like up
in there he was like the right-hand man
there were some murders that he was said
to be responsible for around this period
in 1924 they think that he probably
murdered a guy named Joe Howard and this
was in retribution for an earlier
assault that Howard had undertaken
against a friend of Capone's so you know
he was getting revenge for that now
there was also this prosecutor named
William mcswiggen who actually um tried
to indict Al Capone on this particular
killing of Joe Howard now you will
probably not be surprised to learn that
mcswiggen also ended up dead so you know
that whole thing happened to now at this
point and this was maybe not the wisest
idea because at this point um you know
the italian-american gang which at this
stage the Chicago Outfit was run by
Johnny Torrio and they kind of ran the
south side and the loop now the
irish-american gang noticed the North
Side gang they were running the north
side of Chicago and there had been kind
of an uneasy truce between these two
gangs however um at this point it seems
like they were kind of trying to
encroach on the Irish American gangs
territory and perhaps unwisely they
assassinated the then leader of the
North Side gang who was named Dean
O'Banion he was in his flower shop and
people came in and shot him dead yeah
now this was kind of like the beginning
of this whole like there was a several
year period where they wore a huge like
gang war but you have these two going on
yeah there was a lot of ethnic rivalry
you know the area
the Irish were in this era underdogs to
the Anglo Americans okay but they were
closer to angle my Anglo Americans they
weren't as foreign as Italians in this
era they didn't like this idea of [ __ ]
Italians killing them and taken over and
you know which that's understandable but
nobody really takes client kindly to
being killed but there's a there huge
rivalry broke out between Irish gangs
and Tahlia oh yeah and it went on for
several II went out but another thing
that you have to consider is that as
that developed there was also a lot of
crossover but it was mostly about Irish
guys leaving defeated gangs to kind of
join Italian gangs that happened - yeah
so there was crossover yeah there were a
lot there were there were fake Italians
in these Italian gangs there is like
Italian up there laughs right right
right
they would tell you but you know and it
an Irish can go far in an Italian mob in
this era the only thing that really held
him back he could even be a capo the
thing is he couldn't be a made man that
was the difference yeah you had to prove
Italian ancestry to get made and really
what being made was all about is that
another Italian gangster could not knock
you off without having approval for it
through the chain of command yeah and
and and and a guy who was made could
hire Capo's he could form his own army
basically it was a loose structure but
there was kind of some rules I mean they
were
like pretty organized for a criminal
yeah outfit yeah I think if I remember
correctly and it an Irish they call him
an Irish Irish could be a capo he
couldn't be made yeah yeah so okay so
like I said this kind of like stems you
know like kind of started this whole
rivalry between them now after the
murder of Dean O'Banion sometimes called
Dion O'Banion in his flower shop he had
two associates that were also in the
North Side gang who were named [ __ ]
Weiss and the very famous George bugs
Moran and they tried to kill Johnny
Torrio in 1925 however they were not
successful now this apparently freaked
Johnny Torrio out a little bit um that
and him like spending a little bit of
time in prison around that time so he
just thought you know I'm I'm too old
for this [ __ ] [ __ ]
so he decided to go into retirement now
at this stage he decided to hand the
reins of the Chicago Outfit over to Al
Capone who was then only 26 years old
and he became in this era pretty much
the boss of all of the [ __ ] brothels
the gambling rackets the racketeering
all of that [ __ ] that was going on in
Chicago at the time Al Capone was now
the head of it at 26 years old there's a
lot of power for a young man like it
definitely is a lot of money a lot of
girls a lot of [ __ ] political [ __ ]
poll with the police you could do a lot
with that yeah so he considered he he
wasn't made at this point though was he
do you know I think not no this was like
he was still pretty I mean like I said
he was okay but so at this stage like I
said because Johnny Tory was like a
right amount and he retired and you know
Al Capone was kind of his
second-in-command so he just said okay
will you just take over the [ __ ] now as
I said before about this prosecutor
mcswiggen he got killed some say
accidentally or inadvertently they
weren't really trying to kill him
but because of that
in 1926 Al Capone actually went into
hiding for a little while because he was
like kind of like yeah he thought he was
gonna get spooked yeah retaliated
against in about 1926 but apparently
nothing happened to get but he didn't
get in trouble for it or anything like
that now right around 1927 I guess
they're estimating what I've seen from
various sources was that by 1927 Al
Capone's personal wealth was estimated
about a hundred million dollars yes
guess again that's like in today's
dollars are then dollars holy crap I
don't know I was there would be a
billion dollars per yeah that's [ __ ]
massive so he wasn't like I said there
was a lot of [ __ ] rackets going on
even though he tried to portray himself
as like you know he's a man of the
people like I said he opened up a soup
kitchen during the Depression he would
give large amounts of money to charities
and whatnot and like kind of tried to
portray himself as you know a friendly
guy I'm like friend of the working
people he would give people money it was
a big foreign stuff like that some
people might say at this point in this
story where are the cops at all this but
you have to understand the city police
and even state police in this era of
American history or are not real
professional organizations they're on
par basically with rent-a-cops they're
not well trained they're not well armed
they're not well managed from above
there they're just no match for
organized crime really it wasn't until
later until federal agencies and there
was more reforms later in decades to
come really you didn't really see modern
police work or modern style police
forces in the United States and so after
World War two yeah so when you can go
back in history and read what these guys
did and how they dealt with cops and
interactions between gangsters and cops
that always favored the gangsters they
just bribe the cops away
cops were scared of gangsters that's it
because they would kill
they feel like in a [ __ ] heart like
anyone else all right
because to that when you saw a cop of
that era he was a skinny untrained like
like a mall cop is what they were like
you know with a little maybe a 38
special revolver and well they didn't
have a lot of the training like no
training and yeah no radios no
organization and then the judicial
system that backed them up was corrupted
so the cops had their hands tied they
really just weren't a mind weren't
really a Matalin like I said I think a
lot of the a lot of the problem too was
that when these gangsters would do this
kind of even if they did into public
places like said because some of these
gangsters were gunned down like on book
streets or in restaurants or something
like that you didn't start seeing modern
law enforcement identities until like
the time of Frank Hamer which is this is
in that same era but towards the later
part of it
going out and he was a federal agent who
was a what Texas marshal or I forgot
what he was [ __ ] making myself look
stupid but Hamer actually hunted down
body and Clyde some of the tactics that
he used and you know he had been
empowered by you know federal
authorities to do stuff and really the
experience that they learned through
Hamer that's really when modern policing
was kind of born how to deal with these
damn organized gangs yeah they just
weren't ready for this well yeah I mean
clearly because like I said not only did
they bribe a lot of the cops a lot of
the politicians judges and everything
like that
but because they had a particular
reputation everyone in the city knew who
they were I mean like I said they could
come into a restaurant and just gunned
down somebody they could gunned down in
a public street in the middle of the day
and because the witnesses or any jury
that they would convene yeah at a trial
knew what would happen to them if they
testified against this person everybody
would say I didn't see anything and it
was the same for a beat cop yeah beat
cop and go I shoot that
damn straight they will find out where
my family lives and kill me and my
family my reputation preceded that yeah
yeah yeah and intimidation was also a
rupture they definitely intimidated
witnesses they intimidated jury members
they intimidated you know lawyers judges
anybody that would prosecute them which
is the reason that a lot of them didn't
do much jail time right until much later
on when like law enforcement became like
enough of a force to like actually by
attacking and they had the in the and
the organized crime had the ability to
cast this terror into people because
their fingers were in the system at all
levels oh yeah yeah they're talking
about you know all your mayors and your
[ __ ] representatives they had a lid
money they could erase a lot of palms
it's like it was very easy for them to
just like throw a cache around your or
if if they didn't have enough cash to
throw around and they were just kill you
so you just blow your car up they were
yeah
so it'd be a modern person might want to
look at the gangsters of this particular
era as almost like parallel government
that is essentially what they were they
had government in their [ __ ] pocket
you know so and they had another kind of
thing going on too because they would do
the whole extortion racket where they
you know would go to say small business
owners and they'd say hey I'll protect
you from this rival gang for X amount of
money and if you didn't pay that then
they would blow your [ __ ] up yeah Al
Capone also when he first started doing
the bootlegging you know during
Prohibition that was another thing that
he would do he started like
manufacturing his own beer and if you
didn't buy beer from him then he would
blow your [ __ ] up yeah and everyone knew
that he would blow your [ __ ] up because
he did it a few times yeah so everyone
got right in line well it's just that's
what I mean it's right you have to get
blown up no I don't want to get blown up
to you it's like nobody does and here's
something else sucks but and here's
something else to kind of throw in that
mix according to what I read from the
sources of the time
the higher the the higher up in other
words like the high up gangsters like
Capone and his guys the product that
they sold the beer and the gin it was
mostly beer and gin really some whiskey
you know they got it from whiskey from
Canada yeah they did that the quality
was good yeah very good well it wasn't
like the [ __ ] people were brewing right
it was also weird bathtub [ __ ] [ __ ]
then there was bootleg alcohol we just
made it wanted alcohol god dammit that
was made out of [ __ ] wood alcohol and
making go blind it was bad [ __ ]
some of it was poisonous yeah please
make you go blind so we got gotta give a
[ __ ] gangster credit Capone and his
boys it was good booze they were
supplying product even though they were
making you take it yeah where they would
blow your shop on yeah but evidently it
was a [ __ ] good product but it was
better than better than the competition
better than getting blown up you're also
getting better you know there's a
bathtub gin right and [ __ ] wood
alcohol make it go blind which man I've
read some [ __ ] about that era and this
is like I don't know if I'm desperate
enough yeah like I like drinkin and I
like booze and everything but it's like
if it was outlawed I don't think I'd be
desperate enough to like drink [ __ ]
yeah I don't think I lose your [ __ ]
vision that's what I mean it's it's not
it's not worth it to me though so that
extent your high level [ __ ] Italian
mob at least they had good booze yeah I
mean you can give them that for sure
they were supplying a product that the
public wanted and in yeah even though
like I said that to a certain extent
they were making shop owners you take it
no I'm not throw some Mississippi in
this you know cuz that's just my
heritage at the same time it's going on
we were doing moonshine back there and
this was to begin this was like the
beginnings of NASCAR because rednecks
head of yes soup up their cars and the
other [ __ ] outrun the cops because
you help carry and [ __ ] moonshine in
the back and from those modifications
Maslin is a [ __ ] that's that's Ryan
goes outrunning the [ __ ] cops around
the car
[ __ ] that's where the whole [ __ ] a
NASCAR [ __ ] like I said that's why
there's track in Daytona Beach I was
born in Daytona Beach right across the
street from the [ __ ] night our track
and moonshine acts Hospital moonshine is
good and it's usually corn based well
depending on who makes it right you can
buy it now it's kind of like the
American if you're Brazilian you would
notice ASSA or pinga you know it's a
very high alcohol content oh yeah not a
lot of it it's not something you people
will drink it straight to [ __ ] prove
what a man they are that's really
something you mix it's not enjoyable to
drink straight you know you can make mix
it with punches [ __ ] fantastic
[Laughter]
200-proof like some little bit like that
you're just like [ __ ] yes so we were in
on that too one of the ones that [ __ ]
came out of that scene was a [ __ ]
bullet of moonshine runner accidentally
killed a law enforcement agent and went
to [ __ ] prison for it when the war
started you know he became a weapons
designer with carbine Williams and he
[ __ ] made the gas operating system of
the [ __ ] m1 carbine and in prison was
he was allowed to make that [ __ ] the
prototypes of that [ __ ] carbine that
ended up serving in World War two
he was connected everything's
interconnected booze and gangsters and
warfare and [ __ ] all that [ __ ] [ __ ]
prison and cops see that's what they
mean like change one thing cuz it'll
change there's like ripples and it
changes everything because like I said
there's also ripples in history ripples
in time just like the ripples in this
Dookie you and I sure like the ripples
in tequila it's all connected man got
Mexican we got Mexico touching my brain
is I'm [ __ ] drinkin I'm not even on
LSD right we've got mixtures of Irish
American DNA mixing with [ __ ] Mexican
booze all coming in to bring you a show
in your house while you're working well
actually you know there's senator
pitchers man who is that that was
actually driving a damn front loader
where they were doing heavy construction
while they're in school
yeah yeah it's one of our regulars I
forgot the name I know who it is just
please be careful well the like don't
get distracted by our shenanigans our
shenanigans here we're drinking and
you're out there [ __ ] doing heavy
lifting I mean you know like I work too
but it's Friday night yeah I've already
worked all we here we've worked with I
mean this is still kind of working but
it's still doing all the engineering and
it gets funner as I get drunker even
though I'm sure it gets less fun for the
people listening because I feel like I
probably get less coherent I just like
you're doing good what's next on alcohol
thank you for the for that okay so like
I said there was like so much [ __ ]
gang warfare between the
italian-american gangs and Irish
American gangs now in 1929 Al Capone
made what was probably not the smartest
move and this would be the very famous
Day Massacre
yeah well seemed to be the right thing
at the time I guess like I well I seem
to be they can get away with any
everything's yeah well he thought that
this would be like a steep and this
would like [ __ ] his enemies like they
wouldn't [ __ ] with him anymore and this
was gonna be a big deal but it ended up
kind of blowing up the base a little bit
as I said this happened in 1929 he
overreached he overreached
uh there was retaliation from the feds
with it uh dad yeah so like I said I
feel like this was probably not the best
the beginning of the end it was a bad
idea
yeah he should have just played it cool
fought the war kept the war low-key and
try to keep it out of the [ __ ] you
should have kept it out of the papers as
much as possible instead he was gonna
say no I'm gonna go all-in and the paper
papers are gonna trumpet trumpet my
victory yeah but we're not - maybe
locally but he's thinking you know he he
wasn't thinking about the national level
but how the feds would respond to this
well and also how the public would
respond because yeah I mean what he
ended up doing I mean basically they
were
watching like members of the
irish-american the North Side gang and
then he got them to come to this [ __ ]
warehouse or whatever it was on
Valentine's Day February 14 1929 now he
said like all his guys like more
pretending to be cops and they pretended
it was a raid yeah and they got like
seven dudes is a murder Massacre and
they got him up against the wall like
their hands against the wall and they
just [ __ ] gun them all yeah tommy gun
yeah and the and photographs of that and
you can still I'm probably not gonna put
it in the video because I don't want
this [ __ ] to get deep on its eyes but
like you the photographs of it were
published in the papers at the time cuz
in [ __ ] care
they didn't give a single [ __ ] about
like graphic or anything so they show
like all the [ __ ] bodies like laying
on the floor and like people kind of
turned against that condition because
they're like well okay well Al Capone
was kind of like a cool guy but dude
that's not cool
he's just like they were like they shot
them in the back there's an execution it
was yeah it was essentially an execution
and like it's animated yeah it was they
met up with their enemies in their own
turf where they had a bunch of barrels
of [ __ ] booze it was like a booze
warehouse yeah and they were dressed as
cops that's how they got in there lined
up the enemy gave machine-gun him with
tommy guns yep no prob about time talk
about tommy gun cuz I've been saying it
in this era the Tommy gun became famous
the tops of submachine gun was around
for a long time it was a world war one
actual weapon really even though we
didn't buy a whole lot of them um was a
45 caliber submachine gun used Blish
blocking for a while there's a bunch of
different versions of it but the
gangsters kind of made it famous it was
like in a way the very first assault
rifle and you could buy them brand-new
in full auto configuration from Sears &
Roebuck this is before any national
firework well I hope full auto and sound
suppression they just weren't really
factors in crime
so yeah why control it yeah it wasn't
you know until this error I feel yeah
like a big called the Chicago typewriter
and I was one of the worst one of those
what yeah I want one of the terms for it
really you could but yeah you can buy
them from you can buy it from Sears &
Roebuck mail-order and there was no
background checks there was no concept
of anything like that yeah you could
just buy SEVIS Sears Roebuck had that
big ol catalog Thank You sorter never
show you how can you show up to your
house I usually remember getting those
catalogs in the mail when I was little
they weren't they weren't I was the end
of that era they weren't real anally
retentive about that you know cuz they
figured crime was crime it wasn't
illegal until you killed somebody hmm
you know so you could have it yeah yeah
well in a way it doesn't matter because
if you're a criminal you get that you
easier than you can through the legal
means yeah so a lot of that [ __ ] a lot
of these gun laws and stuffs kind of
[ __ ] crazy
and then um suppressors you know
civilians calm silencers which is kind
of misnomer they're not silent if you
suppress a 9-millimeter it sounds like
an unsuppressed 22 it's still there's no
you know they don't start getting
samurai out they don't start getting
silent until you take something like a
22 and suppress that it kind of sounds
like a BB gun but if you listen to all
the shows it doesn't matter because
there were a lot of murderers that went
and [ __ ] gun people down with [ __ ]
380 and 38:22 without suppressors in a
house and then the house next door never
reported any gunshots suppressors are a
[ __ ] joke really technically you
don't really need one I mean to me I'm
fire of 9-millimeter in my house my
neighbors won't hear it or if they do
here they won't know what it was that's
why we call the cops I mean I've heard
comparisons between the two and it's not
a huge difference to me and honestly if
somebody in the next house over like you
said like gun down their entire family
it's like I'm not sure I would
necessarily even if I did hear it it
wouldn't be like significant enough for
me to be like oh somebody just gunned
down there
family attributed oh maybe somebody's
out doing fireworks like our neighbors
do on the floor yeah why but she
actually looked at all the technical
aspects of it if you were to just the
ATF out Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms who
runs all this they actually want to
liberate suppressors because they don't
think suppressors making the impact on
crime and I'm gonna tell you right now
they don't they would have no impact I
would have to agree with you could you
could just liberate so not a huge
difference it won't make a difference it
won't make a difference I've heard it
like I said I've heard the difference
and it not to me it doesn't sound that
much different it was banning sound
suppressors banning sawed-off shotguns
that won't make any difference because
you can already get a pistol in a
shotgun caliber call it a [ __ ] pistol
instead of a sawed-off shotgun which
does the same thing as a sawed-off
shotgun and it has no impact on crime
whoever's gonna kill anybody would kill
anybody anyway but just what's something
else like I said light impact you have
to have laws but there's have to make
sure there's a certain extent where if
you can get around the law in particular
like if there's very obvious loopholes
or something like that it just seems
like I don't know right it just seems
like there's not much point to but all
the banning of sound suppressors in full
auto all came from this era because of
these gangsters yeah and actually it
didn't impact anything the difference
between full auto and semi auto is small
you might as well just make full auto
legal you could actually you would
probably actually kill less people with
full auto than semi auto when I was in
the Army we fired our m16s mostly on
semi-auto it was more effective full
auto wasted a bunch of ammo mostly you
fired faster but you mostly missed miss
[ __ ]
so it's hype it's hype people kill
people if you have a what you can kill
people with whatever weapon you're given
they're all kind of dangerous and
dangerous guys are always gonna have
them in countries that have [ __ ]
bandim gangsters take over just like
this
and they get weapons you get weapons
from the government because the guys in
the government are just as crooked as
those [ __ ] gangsters they get it sell
to him just look at Brazil Brazil had no
guns whatsoever I got friends over there
right now no guns are for it whatsoever
guns poke proliferate they're everywhere
all the criminals have them we're diggin
of them where'd they get them the
government crooked people in the
government sold them to this people are
imperfect it's better just have a
balance of power that's a nice way of
putting it
it's better than imperfect it's just
imperfect their corrupt naturally it's
better just to have a balance of terror
well it's not too much time it's this
you you have to manage the corruption
yeah that's what you have to do right
it's like you can't let people just like
run wild with their baser instincts
because innocent people would get hurt
yeah you have to like mitigate it
somehow and the best way to mitigate it
is to hold people responsible for the
crimes that they commit you kill
somebody you catch that [ __ ] and you
kill him or you send them to prison for
life but that's not happening in a lot
of these countries I have the same
mother brother in Brazil yeah yeah not
only can can you be a gangster and get
these guns from the cops or whatever
they sell to you you can also kill
somebody a walk well my problem here -
in this particular era because if you
have enough money and you have enough
power and you have enough weaponry and
the police force is not equipped to to
do anything do anything about it
then you can easily intimidate the
authorities that are supposed to protect
the public from you yeah into letting
you skate yeah there's a problem in the
United States right now especially with
younger people that I've been seeing
they think that if you make a law and
you write it down on paper that it's
something that happens the old states
are filled with laws that can't be
fulfilled you have to have a criminal
justice system at a system that holds
people accountable
the crimes that they commit and this
starts at the very very top you know I'm
talking about yeah the rich ruling class
have to be held accountable for the
crimes that they commit that would be
nice and usually what happens is is that
the fish rots from the head the people
at the top are not being held
responsible for their crimes so then all
of a sudden they go sad well you know
what [ __ ] the law
everyone just do whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do this and that's kind of like
out in the Brazil and like I said I
think that's a problem everywhere
there's obviously there more money that
you have the more [ __ ] you can get away
with exactly and that is a big one the
room in this you know back to ancient
Rome the problems always start in the
ruling class and the elite if they can
run amuck everyone everyone can write
well because that's the thing it's like
you know people like my poor ass are
like looking at this be like why the
[ __ ] should I follow the laws they do
they don't right I mean it's like I
don't have the money to like hire a
lawyer clearly you know I saw and I
obviously don't have the desire to do
that kind of stuff but some people do
but it's like if you have enough money
you can get away with essentially
anything right which that should not
happen
everyone should be equally accountable
right but I don't know I don't know I
don't know how as soon as those funds
goal is as soon as those [ __ ] are
allowed to get away with whatever they
want everyone everyone is and then then
you have a failed see yeah it's a
free-for-all becomes a failed state and
I mean everyone like I said ideally
everyone should be held equally
accountable no matter how much money
they have no matter how good the lawyer
I can afford is blah blah blah it's like
I know that's an ideal obviously I don't
think that's ever going to happen
because you know like humans right and
this definitely plays into the time
period we're talking about these with
these gags oh yeah the 1920 the 1920s
the people at the top were not being
held accountable for the crimes they
were committing but they were committing
crimes like drinking okay that should
have never been even so that's what
caused all this [ __ ] I mean just like I
like taking draw
should not be right I need to do like
those drugs should be legal if you want
to get high do it yes [ __ ] high if if
you make them illegal you have
prohibition just like this now you got
drug cartels each other it's dumb it's
like just let them [ __ ] this do it let
them have their chemical bliss [ __ ] them
it's no skin off your nose it's worse if
you prohibit it you know of course cuz
they're causing more crime and then all
of a sudden money just [ __ ] ghost in
the roof because you've utilized it
you've now made it yeah cause it work
right all right on the back end right
just let him have it guess like I said
if the [ __ ] was legal and available no
no one would steal for it no no one
would kill for it
there when we do this gang the price
would plummet people would just buy it
like [ __ ] cigarettes yeah the price
would plummet yeah it would become like
worthless man if you could just get a
Walgreens and buy heroin yeah like you
could buy a pack of cigarettes holy crap
I don't want to do heroin I'm just
saying if people want to do it let him
[ __ ] do yeah I think in that case
that's kind of a [ __ ] touchy case
because that is so dangerous and very
addictive it is but you could aren't
about this is what I would do multiple
things this is how I would do what's
that a selling it I'd give it away for
free I would say if you're a if you're a
heroin addict all you have to do is go
to this Center right here and we'll give
it to you for free that's what well they
used to do that in the UK I don't know
if they still do that they used to do
that when I lived there it wasn't heroin
but it's methadone but yeah and the
[ __ ] money would just fall would
disappear
yeah and then there wouldn't be any
incentive to have a drug to criminalize
a drug cartels would collapse yeah
because there wouldn't be what's that
and that methadone [ __ ] was a joke so
[ __ ] I've known junkies and they said
there was no difference named methadone
in hair that's well that should just
been a damn heroin and then and then
that would have [ __ ] totally
collapsed the
I kind of feel like that was a good idea
that they just like gave heroin addicts
what methadone and you don't give it to
a person who isn't an addict you say
you're an addict no I'm not an addict I
just want hair I wouldn't get a [ __ ] out
of here
well yeah I mean yeah essentially like I
said I used to live in the UK that's
what they used to do people that really
heroin addicts and that had problems
that were being laid hospitalised for it
they would just give you a methadone and
you'd go back just like you would get a
prescription or whatever and I feel like
that kind of like mitigated a lot of the
drug problem right maybe not nowadays
but they did that back in the day and I
feel like that's a better idea Jim and
the shed you have to get rid of the pur
like I said humans are not perfect I was
there during all this manage it so were
you we were kids yeah we watched all
those religious right-wing Republicans
of the 80s the very early 80s mm-hmm
grandstanding yeah about banning all
these [ __ ] drugs and doing all this
draconian shit's not gonna work it
didn't work it got worse it's not gonna
work and they did it using religion as a
[ __ ] excuse what they should have done
and the ATF at the time said and DEA
said no don't do that they'll do that
don't crack down hard on it what you do
is you just open up treatment centers
yeah and [ __ ] go soft on it that's
what most of Europe did right and it
would have worked out a lot better yeah
I do feel like the whole the hardline
[ __ ] that's no don't worry I never do
that like I said we saw the [ __ ]
happened we had alcohol prohibition of
all things how [ __ ] stupid is that
good emails do that [ __ ] no you can't
dumb that [ __ ] you can't do that [ __ ]
you really Pro you can't really do
prohibition on anything like outright
gun bans would just fail organized crime
would like I said I feeling good
anything of like anything of any extreme
you can't have any of this and if any of
that that's never gonna work you have to
write reality doesn't work that way this
reality is all gray area you have to
manage you just manage it you have to
understand what human nature is like
it's like how much of this can we put up
with right you know how much of this may
be minimized
right let's minimize bad behavior let's
maximize like people's happiness let
smack smack you that's all you have to
do it's like it's a [ __ ] continuum
man it's not just like one of the other
you can't ban this bad little crazy [ __ ]
this ban all guns
oh we're just gonna hand that right over
to the [ __ ] Mafia doesn't mean it's
like as much as I know personally I'm
not a big gun fan but it's like you know
even I know it's not realistic I'm a gun
fan particular like right like
particularly in this country it's like
it's not gonna whatever work it's not
gonna what would happen is this
organized crime totally organized crime
ago Oh guns are illegal
okay let's start making machine guns
with silencers and we'll make them cheap
everyone will have a map I think I mean
it's totally gonna be the same thing
that happened with prohibition when they
said oh let's ban all alcohol would get
worse because what would happen was
there be absolutely no controls none
that's what I mean none well and that's
what happened like I said with
prohibition they decided oh well let's
ban all alcohol what happened was that
illegal cartels essentially gangsters
took over the whole distribution right
of alcohol it didn't have any regulation
you don't know a safe it wasn't
poisonous I mean people died from
drinking that [ __ ] went blind because
they just made like some horrible [ __ ]
out of what alcohol would alcohol or
like some [ __ ] that was like people are
not supposed to drink and people drank
it because where the [ __ ] else are you
gonna get it and then you look at what
the reasons why they ban this [ __ ] and
when it really comes when you really
look down to its religion it's some kind
of a moral thing alcohol has to be
banned because jesus said so well
there's a weird and this has to be
banned because it's bad this is saying
just if you don't like it don't [ __ ]
do it I can't really this is kind of
something that there's like a really
strong thread of this in American
culture I think it's like some kind of
like weird like Protestant work ethic
type of thing where it's like if it's
enjoyable then it must be best gotta be
bad you like it we gotta get rid of this
there's really a strong current of that
you don't like Americans are also like
you know super like into debauchery or
whatever but it's like there's also this
other kind of thread on the other side
where it's like anything that like is
fun we can't be doing that because there
if it's fun it must be bad or wrong in
some fashion you know anything that
people enjoy drinking drugs prostitution
right we have to like just ban that yeah
it's [ __ ] ridiculous and I don't
think that's ever going to work I guess
that's not how humans work I'm 50 from
the American point of view I would
probably be considered right-leaning or
on the right but the thing is I have
nothing to do with like say right
leading people from say like my parents
generation it [ __ ] has changed a lot
like I have no problem with prostitution
as long as it was controlled that's what
I mean you know how old the girl is you
make sure that [ __ ] the day medical
check-ups that you know I mean there
should be the lice honestly and here I
have no problems with drugs
I don't either I think that MIT people
should if they want to believe people
have the right to what the eighteen
hundreds they called it the right to
chemical bliss if you want to get high
get [ __ ] high it's nothing no skin
off my nose I'd rather have you getting
high and OD in and dying didn't have
these [ __ ] drug cartels come in here
machine gun and people making a [ __ ] ton
of money off [ __ ] crap drugs it's no
skin I don't give a [ __ ] I got I don't
care yeah do what you want to do is you
don't talk about it's all this [ __ ]
weird morality crap that's shove down
like I said and you know just for the
record I am a very very left she left
I'm right person and we get along we go
we agree on this issue I'm like if this
is something that you were just doing to
your own body if you want to drink
yourself to death if you want to do hair
I give [ __ ] if you want to go to
prostitutes that is none of my business
I don't care who you have sex with as
long as they are consenting I don't give
a [ __ ] about anything that you do in
your bedroom I don't care what gender
you are I don't care it's like just do
what you want to do man
right yeah do what you want I'm not
judging we do I believe in an open
society where nobody's shoving and other
people's [ __ ] down somebody else's
throat do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do that's what I mean it's just like and
honestly I'm not even like even though
I'm a little bit I mean personally I'm
kind of anti all religion because you
know I've been an atheist since I was a
kid but if people want to believe yeah
this that and the other believe it
doesn't as long as it doesn't influence
right the laws that you want to pass and
you want to like impose on me yeah yeah
don't do that or a secular society yeah
yeah yeah I'm a myth assist I I'm an ex
Christian but I'm a myth assist all
right I believe that religions are myths
but that doesn't mean that they're not
true and that doesn't mean that they're
bad I believe that there's a value in
religions for some people sure yeah and
depending on what religion it is and how
its expressed you know I'm not a
fundamentalist but I think religions can
help people get through hard times
yeah make sense out of the world or
their stories that help to help you to
establish a it kind of like a moral
compass and the way you're gonna do I
don't have any problem with that that's
what we religion is for you know you
know what the real deal that what RIT
what religion is really for and for me
religion is a way to help you face death
we're all ya know people need that then
I like I said I am not bothered that's
just for if you're just using it as a
moral compass of yours Oh like I said as
long as you were not imposing it on the
people or using it to like yeah I don't
believe in asked out like don't do that
but like if you wanna like whatever you
want to believe yeah you know outside of
those parameters I believe in this
Crusaders you jihadi mentality of making
you believe what I believe I mean it's
like well any kind of fundamentalism
and I had been like that since I was a
child any kind of fundamentalism
authoritarian is the second that you say
I know what's better for you than you do
right
I am opting out of that yeah and if you
guys think I'm bullshitting go back to
our other
episode where dr. Robert and price came
on and we talked about mythos ISM and
Jesus Christ myth or you know you know
we talk about Christianity these stories
about Christianity are valuable but you
have to understand where they came from
and what they are you know you can't
they were never meant to be imposed upon
non-believers you know that's like I
said I mean it's far less not as much to
them as you think that there are I've
always like here's the thing the only
Creed if it can be called that that I
ever adhere to you know my rights to
swing my arm and at your face yeah so as
I said the st. Valentine's Day Massacre
kind of a massive PR blunder on the part
of Al Capone's yeah well I kind of feel
like he thought it would like help him
like propel him to like yeah oh look I'm
such a badass but really because of the
reporting on it at the time the you know
the whole media surrounding it and you
know the fact that the media published a
lot of the photographs yeah from the
[ __ ] make it look real grisly that
didn't help either because it looked
like essentially well what it was was
that these dudes were like duped into
coming to this place and the more
essentially gunned down they were
unarmed they often were shot in the back
Alfonse overreached she's not at that
far yeah a little bit so you know seven
guys brutally gunned down in a warehouse
on Valentine's Day of 1929 didn't go as
well as he was expecting also in 1929 Al
Capone ended up serving ten months in a
prison in Philadelphia after a
conviction concerning carrying a
concealed handgun so this was kind of
like the beginning of the end now
because prosecutors couldn't get him on
they knew they wouldn't be able to get
him on racketeering
charges murder charges any of the other
you know kidnapping and if they're like
major charges well he was too distanced
from all that cuz ya not to he hadn't
ever proven yet other people do it he
had like muscle kind of like he
intimidated witnesses he intimidated
juries and things like that no no
written records or evidence to prove
that he [ __ ] straight executive
orders he was very this is this is
before the advent of the RICO Act yeah I
don't maybe was Rico was Rico actually
invented for this case you know what it
may have been I didn't research that but
it might it may have been okay well
maybe we'll look into that later if it
didn't come up but this was before the
idea of RICO case and a [ __ ] was
what was was really solidified and in
order to take you down organized crime
figures you have to have that be you
have to have the ability to Rico
somebody yeah
which is a totally different way of
investigating [ __ ] crime it's tailored
in the United States it's a process
tailored to fight organized crime you
don't need as much evidence yeah yeah
yeah because that's essentially hundred
eight how they ended up getting it right
I mean the thing about it and this was
actually I think I believe it was a
female
District Attorney a judge I can't
remember what she was her name was Mabel
Willa something will burn you didn't
write it down I did but I can't repair
it as my note yes she drove but um but
yeah so she decided that it's like okay
well maybe we can get him on a lesser
charge but enough lesser charges that we
can put him in prison for a long time
and she said well for a test case let's
prosecute this other guy that we have
you know on similar charges and see if
that sticks like with the Supreme Court
so she like tested it out beforehand
right so they did that beforehand with
this one guy and they said okay well we
can do this whole tax evasion thing but
like what she was kind of shooting for
and it worked like it passed like
Supreme Court muster or whatever so she
said okay well go away
with that [ __ ] without Capone so very
famously yeah Al Capone even though he
had murdered multiple people or ordered
the murders or ordered the murder of
multiple people even though he had done
kidnappings and various other criminal
you know charges they said well let's
try to get him on enough counts of tax
evasion to put him away for a long
enough time and you know paramount to
that was like proving how much income
that he had from like illegal sources
right and there was apparently I was for
like reading a Wikipedia page about this
and it was like kind of fascinating for
a dork like me but it's also if you're
into like law also a fascinating case
because all the [ __ ] they had to go into
to like prosecute him for this
particular kind of set of circumstances
because there was all this like kind of
argument about like well all the money
that he spent in this particular City
can that be allowed or this like was was
that part of his income or not so it was
like this huge thing but eventually they
did end up they charged him on the
initial case with 23 counts of tax
evasion now he did get convicted of only
three counts of that but that was enough
to put him in prison which was what they
wanted to do tax what tax evasion was
his Achilles heel yeah they may they had
a really good movie called The
Untouchables was about this actual case
yeah watch that I haven't seen any movie
ghosts
[ __ ] awesome that's an awesome
gangster movie how they got how they got
Al Capone they just wanted him in prison
they didn't care how they did it they
don't want to find some [ __ ] angle
yeah and but every angle they share
bunch of nerds figured out how to put
this [ __ ] see that's what nerds
run the board power got it that's why it
because they were like well we know we
can't get my murder because no one will
testify because they're terrified of him
right or you know of what will happen if
they do testify but the numbers didn't
add up you get him on tax evasion yeah
get him on something that will be
expecting we have to come at him from
like some other angle man so that's what
they did yeah they got him from [ __ ]
tax evasion because he was not shy about
like spending a [ __ ] ton of money about
like he bought like a big fancy house in
Florida he bought some other things like
he spent a lot of money in like brothels
and whatnot and casinos so they said
well we can use that to show that he had
like a particular income in this
particular year and a lot of it wasn't
you know there I bet you claimed to the
government to pay taxes on and the fact
that perhaps stupidly Al Capone offered
to play to pay taxes on a couple of
years of his income and he offered to
pay taxes on like a hundred thousand
dollars a year which is like kind of a
lot so the government kinda like hmm
well then he must be making more than
that or at least that much right so we
can at least get him on that because he
didn't pay taxes for these particular
years on that yeah so it was like a huge
legal yeah I wasn't really expecting
this line of attack from that's why it
was genius right he needed a lawyer he
needed a really good Jewish tax lawyers
what do you need to defend him from this
but he didn't see it coming because he
like I said that's why I had he had he
had the right Khanna lawyers behind him
to really account for everything he
probably could have distanced himself
from these possessions that he actually
had you know Tom because he well he was
smart enough to not put anything into
your name like I believe but he wasn't
living in a lot of this well I believe
that even like the mansion that he
bought in Florida I believe he put that
in his wife's name as far as I recall so
he knew enough not to put [ __ ] like that
like major purchases in a name but he
still spent an inordinate amount of
money yeah on you know restaurants
brothels all that kind of stuff and like
people noticed that kind of [ __ ] a guy
who would he should have gotten away
from the [ __ ] Italian lawyers and
gotten a really good
Jewish tax lawyer she asked me in those
era in that era because he could have
defended himself from this yeah we just
didn't see the attack coming well like I
said yeah at this point it was like
there that's all we can get him on and
we want him in prison yeah the feds the
feds and Eliot Ness for coming down on
him and that was that was a [ __ ]
brilliant plan of attack it wasn't
against Capone because that was his
weakness yeah didn't cover all like he
said that was something that he hadn't
counted don't think they would actually
come at him from such a pussy-ass angle
but he should have known that that's
that that a gangsters got to cover all
of his ankles see all your races yeah
somebody yeah yeah even if you think
it's not a big deal other people are
gonna see that yes he should have been
so good he should have been so good with
the IRS that the IRS owed him money
right but here's the weather your al
capone or bono or anyone else there's
always a [ __ ] out there smarter
than you are
well so either you have to be smarter
than everyone else on earth or you have
to hire a bunch of people it was that
collectively are smarter than him it was
it was another era and I guess taxi tax
evasion and Ted was not taken as
seriously back then but that was I
suppose is like [ __ ] slide on yeah
the the world learned after but like I
said well yeah I feel like cuz this was
a very famous case of like Al Capone who
had murdered they don't know how many
people who would kidnap Doug they don't
know how many people well his
organization did yeah either him or
someone that he hired to do it and they
ended up getting him on tax evasion and
sending him to jail so as I said he was
indicted in 1931 for twenty two twenty
three counts of income tax evasion for
the years 1925 through 1929 now they
also attempted to charge him with some
other kind of like Prohibition era laws
I don't know
well that worked out but he was only
found guilty on three of the 23 counts
but that was enough to sentence him to
11 years in prison yeah and a $50,000
fine now according to other people who
served time with Al Capone he really did
not like prison it was not something
that suited in his personality um he
actually needed protection
yeah from larger and scarier dudes he
got beat up on a pretty regular basis so
I you know I feel like reading about
this and particularly whoever wrote the
Wikipedia page was obviously like this
[ __ ] got beat up and I'm kind of happy
about it but it seemed like that kind of
situation we're out on the street he was
like this big tough guy he could light
he had all these lackeys that would like
go and kill people when he said to his
money in this gang protective yeah but
when he was in prison right he was kind
of like bottom of the totem pole yeah
and because everybody knew who he was
they were a gun everybody was out to get
him I mean like he got stabbed it's like
he had to like they were trying to make
a name for themselves and he own and
Capone had gotten kind of soft out on
the street I mean he lived a life with
an executive really well yeah I mean
like a man she had everybody he did [ __ ]
for him sure by the time he got locked
up you know you had a lot of street
thugs down there trying to make a name
for themselves yeah how tough they were
yep now he did hat he did have the power
to get himself into a private cell he
had saw it you know I saw it on a
documentary about it he made his way
into a pretty nice cell it had carpeting
it had nice bed I think it had a piano
and some lounge chairs so he was good he
was safe inside his own cell but when it
came time to go get chow and to do stuff
with other prisoners he was getting hit
pretty regular then yeah it's pretty
much and which kind of surprises me that
guys didn't come to
they'd knowing that he only had 11 years
because what that meant is at 11 years
that within reason especially after
they've been in for a couple years that
he would have been free eventually well
he could have offered an ex-con a good
job for watching out for him but the way
it went down he also had syphilis and
that was [ __ ] him up and it weakened
in Milwaukee and was in prison and by
the time he got out he didn't really
want anything to do with with the
[ __ ] gangster life after that that's
what I was gonna charge they I mean they
estimate I mean he wasn't in prison all
that long but he already had syphilis
like I said from all the hookers he
ruler than [ __ ] yeah and by the time he
was let out of prison I mean he was
basically or you know by the time like
later on his sentence yeah he was
basically like a 12 year old child
actually like sub 12 year old child um
some of the letters that were written to
people that he knew like from prison in
those later years he was pretty much
incomprehensible um so it wasn't a type
of thing where he was in like his right
said in mind I mean Sifl is pretty much
you gave him up kind of you could kind
of say he died in prison because who
came out of there was not the same Al
Capone no yeah so in a way he kind of
vanished in prison but it was if he
asked me sad demise for the guy yeah I
don't think he had a whole lot of blood
on him on his hands personally I think a
lot of the [ __ ] that happened
his organization did automatically
through standing orders I mean gangsters
do certain things automatically to
protect the organization that they
belong to so I'm sure a lot of guys that
got killed by his organization he
probably he probably didn't know or
didn't adore me now let's do it on their
own but you know some guys just do [ __ ]
on their own there's no way of knowing
that there's no way to know it was a
different era you know but as I said I
mean he died of complications from
syphilis
in you know 1947 yeah he survived the
incarceration lived a long time here in
Florida with his wife in that damn house
he did how long was it do you remember
you got written down um he nine years I
think I think that what happened he
served a couple years in a penitentiary
in Atlanta and then in 1934 he got
transferred to Alcatraz and then in 1939
he got released and he went into a
hospital in Baltimore and that was when
he was still he was in late-stage
syphilis at that point so he did what
five six minutes after they let him out
he went to his mansion in Florida and
his wife kind of took care of him until
1947 and he eventually died so he was
only had a cardiac arrest
so Kelly are you done yeah he wasn't he
didn't live very long after he got into
prison and like I said from people that
served with him like in prison at the
time they pretty much said that he was
toast huh yeah like as soon as he came
in he didn't like ever like he said
everyone was gunning for him yeah
because he was a big name and he got
stabbed he got [ __ ] with he got just
constantly and essentially had like a
nervous breakdown and he was also
suffering from symptoms of late-stage
syphilis yeah all that time too so he
was mentally deteriorating this whole
entire time so it like I said it was a
very ignominiously for ya he really
didn't go out with a bang as they say
I'm sure he probably would have been
happier being like gunned down
yeah maybe yeah probably right I feel
sorry for a while I know for a big Alex
because he was a horrible person but I
think everybody was kind of a horrible
person in that era that I don't feel bad
for any even though he was just one of
the players in Chicago at the time you
know I mean it's just he got locked up
he had syphilis the world changed who I
was locked
he didn't make even really make it out
yeah but you know that's how it happens
he had a good run while he was out there
yeah that should happen better than just
happens to everyone and it way he went
down at least that was better than just
dying an unknown [ __ ] person and some
kind of an Italian ghetto
I guess like people do still remember
him now they still make movies about the
mother son you know yeah now after he
died in 1932 what is she doing oh I
gotta show him oh my goodness [ __ ] is
that look at this look what she does
what we are doing the show fell asleep
always like water back on her back
asleep is she looking yeah no she's not
looking she's got her eyes closed fell
asleep she fuzz she seems like a person
she thinks she's a human being okay
why you acting like it's all weird so
after the you know after Al Capone was
incarcerated leadership of the Chicago
Outfit passed on to his successor who
he'd actually picked and this guy was
called frank the enforcer' nitti okay
yeah now he had been a bodyguard at
first and then kind of like worked his
way up in the bootlegging operation
although he was actually not he was not
the guy that was making the decisions it
was actually another guy named Paul the
waiter Ricca
who was actually met like I said I love
these [ __ ] all the waiter right the
waiter was he waiter at once that I
guess but like I said it's like in some
ways like some of the some of the
[ __ ] nicknames like Scarface that's a
good nickname that Al Capone didn't like
it but others like the waiter the waiter
yeah that's kind of like it's been a
waiter at what time that's what I mean
it's like come on come on
something a little bit I forgot about
yeah I didn't I don't know about this
guy [ __ ] hell but yeah so he was
supposedly the one that was like kind of
behind the scenes like pulling the
strings right so then it kind of passed
into that leadership now prohibition as
I said we we all kind of realized how
stupid an idea it was so it was repealed
in 1933 and at this stage the Chicago
Outfit were like well [ __ ] that gon cut
the legs right so we have to go back to
focusing on what we were doing before
prostitution labor racketeering did a
lot of that welcome people from rambling
you know yeah like holding people for
ransom like I said like some black hand
[ __ ] from the early 20th century they
had to wait around till cocaine appeared
before they could get back into the
money and that was [ __ ] late even then
it was kind of like too late for them
cuz like I said it was you know really I
feel like the 1920s was sort of their
heyday heyday I mean they're still
around now but at a substantially
diminished capacity like it was it's
just really not the same and law
enforcement or more attuned to that
nanotechnology if I can track them down
exactly so it's it's not really the same
situation as it was back then it's like
back then it's kind of like everything
was wide open you could kind of do
whatever you wanted if you had enough
money like I said if you had enough
money power charisma you could pretty
much do what you wanted which is kind of
true nowadays but less so than back then
they had to wait till the las vegas era
started to come back later trails you
know then they got more into that and
[ __ ] they live the high life for a
while yeah there's all kinds of good
movies about it you'll see well yeah
beacon whoa I was just gonna say because
after this stage like after prohibition
I did and they got more into gambling
and um you know the waiter kind of
expanded things into other markets
including like Missouri Wisconsin Las
Vegas Los Angeles and they kind of like
took over control of a bunch of like
casinos so they kind of
that for a while like I said please go
see the movie Casino cuz it's actually
very good and it's actually based on a
true story about some [ __ ] that happened
around this time they all have that
[ __ ] what's his name what's his name
Al Pacino the other guy which one De
Niro Oh Robert any area yeah so generic
plays a good gangster but you have to
understand something
he's just playing a gangster [ __ ] he
could play a gangster but I have beat
that [ __ ] is he's always he's not as
uh anger I can talk about I just I think
it's funny when you got a guy throws his
weight around in real life like he's a
gangster that dude is not a gangster he
said actor he plays gangsters but he
acts like a gangster in real life funny
how this funny a lot funny how these
[ __ ] mobsters haven't knocked that
[ __ ] off Fred they must like it I
don't know the thing is though it's like
I feel like there's kind of like some
[ __ ] where if you're a good enough actor
there's gonna be like some overlap
between cuz playing a gangster he's not
a real game great like I'm not an actor
so I don't know yeah like I'm not good
at like I think you portraying myself
by other people I think De Niro
convinced himself that he's against
that's what I'm saying but yes so some
people that are actors might get so like
because he's played gangsters alive yeah
yeah he now thinks he's a gangster which
maybe that's the case I will beat his
[ __ ] ass all right no heard it here
first
oh yes De Niro even though he's like 90
years is going to be well you know
that's all fun I have to burst your
[ __ ] balloon itself it's all fun
engaged I was just playing
that's why cuz you know I just have to
like it's all fun I love it
I love De Niro's work in the gangster
movies I do I do
he did he disagreed said he did a great
job [ __ ] and if you can pretend to be
something against me that you're that
something right and I've just seen him a
couple times in my obliging waxen
showing up like he's like he's really a
gangster
you know all their names but a missus
told them yeah yeah go out there and
talk to pretend like you're pretend like
he's like really I don't really want to
do it no like no do it yeah [ __ ] De
Niro he's a little he's kind of method
though it'd me yeah and yeah a lot of
actors of that era are there very method
yeah which I don't know if you guys are
young that means like be the medics like
living you live the [ __ ] rules while
you're doing the role you're right I'm
like living there all sure so I feel
like he's kind of from that school of
actors as a lot of actors were I get his
mind right though about who's a gangster
who isn't you're gonna beat up in 1900
man I was back in the day I'm talking my
back although probably pretty close
right he's in his seventies still no
yeah dude that's like so much older than
you don't be like that
I'm just drunk talking don't take it
seriously this is just part of the show
okay
I [ __ ] I'll tell you what what the
untouchables was a good gangster movie
it really was yeah I liked it very much
come on oh you know you know is good the
masterpiece of all gangster movies with
pride me The Godfather one and it's new
obviously I'm gonna say that three not
so much but I have a soft spot in my
heart for Goodfellas yeah and I think
doesn't like Goodfellas and I think and
I think what's his name little uh little
Joe Pesci yeah Joe Pesci he made that
[ __ ] in my boat in my mind actually
kinda that's that's the way that's the
way the gangsters were there were more
like Joe Pesci I do kind of feel like
that yeah yeah that is yes accurate
you're not talking about [ __ ] physical
super bandit
they're Italian guys who were [ __ ]
wily a [ __ ] kind of average size and
build who [ __ ] mean and ruthless and
but probably funny because everything
I've ever read or heard of [ __ ]
gangsters and gangsters that I've [ __ ]
seen in the Boston area that real
gangsters [ __ ] they were [ __ ]
funny like okay well you know when I
lived in Boston I lived in Winter Hill
and [ __ ] I saw the Winter Hill Gang
yeah yeah
they were [ __ ] there one of their
little I ain't gonna say nothing [ __ ]
Whitey Bulger and all those guys I guess
but he's died though but he's dead he's
got guys running around also I feel like
he murdered some people that he didn't
get copper yeah yeah but I've seen those
guys on several occasions they I've seen
those guys on several occasions they had
they had some buildings around where I
lived
yeah and I'd see him in the middle of
the night if I can pull security and
blocking off roads to [ __ ] you know
load and unload stuff I ain't a same or
whatever they were doing yeah and
[ __ ] I said what's up man how you
doing what's your name - Tom and where
you live I said I'm right here in this
building man don't lie to me and that's
it nowadays let me see your ID that's
already you live there okay all right go
ahead go okay well here's the funny
thing about looking down my way on holy
crap the funny thing about the Winter
Hill Gang is that when you looked at
them that to me they look like they were
cosplaying as gangsters I mean they they
dressed that like that well then guns
will kill anyone I had gods too though
for them right but guns won't kill
anyone depending on it doesn't matter
what you're dressed like yeah we can I
saw him in a play and I looked at them
I'm like oh right
I wasn't gonna [ __ ] with him dude you
could have seriously if things had gone
differently you could have got murdered
by Whitey Bulger and I would be that was
that wasn't invited my books
it wasn't whitey I seen pictures of
white
because he might have killed this one
woman that was found on [ __ ] yeah you
know it wasn't whining though with
somebody that worked with him I didn't
see whitey benzene it was the rest of
the gang I saw Mom he just died this I
saw him on three different occasions
living on Winter Hill yeah yeah I could
show you right off I can I can show you
where that where they were
I [ __ ] I think those guys are all going
there probably they are actually
probably be afraid of me so you guys out
there if you if something bad happens to
us if we don't like possession Oh like
in a couple weeks you know what happened
that case is over with but [ __ ]
blabbed that could that case is over
with but I did see them and I know the
buildings that they owned or at least
the one that was near my house yeah or
it was the house as an apartment right
there on [ __ ] that's pretty they're
all gone now though now yeah I have
but looking I didn't know who they were
at the time I had heard the Winter Hill
Gang
yeah and a song and then I was like this
must be who it is that they're talking
about so I just kind of cooperated I was
coming back from the club coming back
from [ __ ] memories lovely I don't
want any [ __ ] trouble man I'm [ __ ]
dressed up about day veiny like [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] shoot me play and I see a
guy who looks like he's cosplaying like
a gangsters and his gangster splinter
blocking off the entire road and I'm
going oh that place yeah no wonder yes
never open okay I thing to do with me
you go home what's your name my name is
I don't lie to me listen all right this
is the new CID that said of mind II
think it's okay man let him live on go
ahead and go on good thing you didn't
say nothing
they said huh there's a long time I
wouldn't've either like I said there's
gonna dudes I mean you know I was
everything I was just coming
the army I was packing - well then the
thing is like if you're a gangster you
want to kill some other gangster every
little beef that's in this deal they
disrespectful he was respectful
respectful I was respectful I knew it I
knew what it was don't [ __ ] touch my
tits or nothing and I knew by myself
over there we'll go in my house and I
will not go ahead go ahead this now
before you give me a trouble at this
time at this time in history those dudes
are all [ __ ] [ __ ] they should be
worried about me oh yeah I mean like I
said after prohibition that was that was
kind of their heyday and honestly like
after the 1940s about 1943 there was
like a huge scandal with like where the
one of the gangsters in Chicago had a
temp wolf not even attempted they did do
it they infiltrated all of the unions in
Hollywood and were like influencing like
you know Hollywood film and the studio
system everything like that so
eventually they got kicked out when
Jonathan II came in they he kind of like
crack down on that whole [ __ ] which yeah
which they hated that [ __ ] and I'm like
I don't want I'm not going to talk about
Carlos Marcellus yet okay okay I'm going
to talk about cosmos I figured the
Italians were always pissed on why they
couldn't get the president seeing the
[ __ ] and and and the Irish mob could
because Kennedy was descendants of Irish
mob they had they had some other kind of
mob that was happening in New Orleans
all right I'm gonna talk about Carlos
Marcellus Carlos Marcellus was the dude
that was kind of hooked up with Edwin
Edwards who ended up being the governor
of New Orleans eventually well
Marcellus was linked in with a guy who
was had alopecia was kind of a weird
[ __ ] from the CIA who was
involved with the free Cuba movement
with the CIA good
now in this free cubed movement was a
dude named Lee Harvey Oswald yeah I was
just okay and it looks like Lee Harvey
Oswald killed Kennedy because Carlos
Marcello send this ex-cia dude [ __ ]
wanna [ __ ] I'm John under a grudge match
why is why could the Irish get the
presidency and the Italians could yeah
but I'm gonna leave it at that I didn't
say that about here you didn't see me no
okay saying there is there's a good
chance that the [ __ ] air I am la
Brown there is a giant thought that says
that perhaps the associate the
assassinations of John F Kennedy and
Robert Kennedy's head are tied in with
the Mafia and that there was some mafia
connection there the Italian mob
essentially assassinating them because
they are doing great books your drink
called mafia kingfish that's a nothing
that's about call us Marcellus so there
might I'm not saying I don't know one
way the other if you ask me I'll read
the book if I read the book if you ask
me JFK was killed under the orders I'm
gonna tell you mafia kingpin I mean it's
a possibility Marcellus like I said with
the CIA yeah I'm alright and with the
help of the CIA because some other [ __ ]
that happened with Bay of Pigs in yeah
there was a whole sorry there was a
whole that's a whole other show deep
state action that's a whole other show
deep state action because there was a
whole other like association with like
an attempts to kill Fidel Castro that we
had all other mob thing with Italian mob
Whitey Bulger and the and the Whitey
Bulger and the [ __ ] Winter Hill Gang
that all links up to the deep state
Muller this Muller investigation going
on now the guys are the best Mahler knew
Whitey Bulger there was some [ __ ] that
went on with that
that's all I'm he didn't hear it from me
I didn't say this on the show I didn't
talk about any more about it
I'm gonna talk more about it he's gonna
get bombed on I need to get well
that's the thing though I'm not the only
one to say this
not the only one to say that says this
[ __ ] there's other people to say this
mafia has always had a connection with
the intelligence agencies and certain
aspects of the United States government
going back to World War two with
overthrowing Mussolini and needing
gangsters to help form a new government
after the [ __ ] Mussolini was
overthrown this [ __ ] goes way back yeah
like I said MKULTRA [ __ ] and LSD and
throwing [ __ ] out of window I'm
just saying that there are some I'm just
trying to make a show yeah they're just
I got no proof of this I can't go in
Fermilab or say there's no reason to rub
me out because I got no evidence this is
all stuff in the you know I'm I'm just
trying to cover my ass
okay how knowing I didn't say this like
I said I just got this [ __ ] from like
Wikipedia biography page I just I've
never said you knew this I was not here
I'm just saying there's some that
believe that the assassination of JFK
the assassination of Robert Kennedy was
tied in with mafia yeah involvement yes
I don't know
now after that happened because of the
whole yeah kind of crackdown that
happened in the wake of that there has
been obviously the mob the Chicago
Outfit still exists but to a much lesser
extent than in the past particularly
after the whole like exposure of their
like cracked out like you know there are
infiltration of unions in Hollywood they
kind of got kicked out of that tonight
I'm not worried anything I'm gonna say
anything about these guys because I
wasn't here to seeing this but this come
on there was a big difference between
the age of the old mob and then what
happened later with cocaine and the
[ __ ] Colombian and Mexican drug
cartels the ruthlessness of the calm
being the Mexican drug cartels if she
asked me kind of [ __ ] push the
Italians out of business
hoarsely because the Italians had been
in the United States for many
generations by this point yeah and they
had better options by the time all this
is going on a lot of the children and
grandchildren of these mobsters so they
went to [ __ ] college and they got
other cottages they had normal eyes like
the economy they went straight okay so
they just times changed yeah that's a
good way it's interesting to say big
things moved up in the world well it's
interesting because I feel like the
public perception is that the height of
the Italian mob
you know heyday was the 1920s like now
Capone or all the shootouts and stuff
like that but actual the actual heyday
was actually 1767 when you know when
people had kind of like not really had
kind of like lost that wasn't like this
whole like romantic like culture around
them they that was when they were like
infiltrating all the unions and they
were infiltrating all the casinos and
they were doing all this kind of [ __ ] so
that was when they were that kind of at
the height of their power but like I
said after the whole you know
assassination assassination of JFK and
the whole like law enforcement crackdown
against them like when law enforcement
became powerful enough to fight back
against what they were trying to do then
their influence began to dwindle and
even though they are still around as far
as I know to this date they like their
power is significantly diminished at
this point so I feel like you know in
all the movies and [ __ ] like that it's
kind of like we still bro mantis eyes
the 1920s [ __ ] they even did like a
[ __ ] musical about it there were
times when there were certain Mafia
families that were reduced to run around
cutting off the tops of [ __ ] parking
meters for money you know what I mean I
don't know if it's that bad anymore but
that's pretty sad yeah and then you know
as time progressed then you had guys
kind of like the [ __ ] Iceman
Kuklinski yeah that was mostly seventies
and eighties then there was things that
happened in Detroit during time that I
was in the Detroit area with an O
what's his name Gotti John Gotti and all
those guys tell me one Don yeah
Gotti was kind of like the the JFK of
all gangsters you know he shows up into
the gangster scene makes everybody feel
important [ __ ] he becomes kind of like
he kind of will I don't see I don't say
he weasels his way into the Mafia he
actually just kind of [ __ ] what he
loves his way into it you know talking
about it shows that made gangster feel
so important next thing you know he's a
DA because he made these gangsters feel
important and then he starts doing [ __ ]
you know I mean yeah I got he was an
interesting character - totally
self-made man yeah yeah yeah stuff
that's happening in bars and Casilla in
bars and clubs this is where this all
starts these are social [ __ ]
movements really they just happen to be
criminal social movements but yeah you
know it's much better yeah for your
criminal enterprise if you have a lot of
like friends and supporters around you
who is like you all pure charisma yeah
like if you're a dick no one's gonna
like if something goes bad no one's
gonna like stand up for your ovens in
like yeah [ __ ] behead that mother god
I hate that dude
God he's strength was that he was this
guy who was tall and good-looking and
dressed well came out of nowhere and
just showed up to the scene and made
gangsters feel important again if I can
got them all together and became their
warrior king really you know and he
wrote rewrote the rules he kind of
revived revived the Italian mafia in
Detroit for a while you know didn't last
forever but yeah and as I said I mean
even in 2005 the Department of Justice
they started operation family secrets
and that ended up in dining 14 members
of the Chicago Outfit and its artists
under under Rico laws okay so that was
that was kind of like a huge thing
that's
yeah sucked the air out of that show
right there yeah so as far as I know as
of 2007 the official size the Chicago
Outfit is said to only comprise 28
official member oh yeah that's a small
crew and about about another hundred
like clinger orange which means that the
[ __ ] Hells Angels is huge compared to
them that's what I mean so they're our
influence has significantly diminished
since law enforcement is kind of caught
up with them and like knows what they're
up to and there are laws like made that
will indict them for particular things
they've also been infiltrated by federal
yeah yeah why not so moral of the story
is right now if you want to be anything
like a gangster you probably what's want
to be a motorcycle gang in a motorcycle
gang
if that's your language the Mongols or
in some of the other reefer kill anybody
or you know they have a lot of money
from my understanding they have a lot of
money yeah so you know if you're if
you're looking to get into that kind of
join a motorcycle yeah like I said don't
be like raping and killing or anything
like that indiscriminate latest you know
person all right so let's wrap up this
wrap it up Jim rambling drunken episode
like every single other everything
alright rambling it was at under fifty
two about Al Capone and the Chicago
Outfit gangsters in general we all love
that [ __ ] so hope you guys enjoyed it
remember if you've liked the show like
share subscribe on all your social media
if you would like to financially support
the show we would much appreciate it you
go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
dirty and clog podcast on WordPress icon
there's a little button in the sidebar
we can go to a PayPal account and give a
PayPal donation a one-time donation if
you don't like patreon for whatever
reason that would also be much
appreciated
remember our regular episodes just like
this one come out every Tuesday
Monday if you're a patron also we have
movie retrospectives usually old movies
usually horror sci-fi that comes out
every Friday or Thursday appear a patron
and we also have 13 o'clock matinee two
or three new movies in the theater which
comes out every Sunday or Saturday if
you're a patron so check those out if
you haven't already and we will see you
next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]